guys the day's finally come here it is
go to www.dope as usual dot store and we
have the sketchy tee with the black and
white we also have the pullover sweater
we have shorts and beanies the link will
be in the description of this video or
go to www dot dope as usual dot store
[Music]
what is up guys how are you doing
welcome back to the dope as usual
podcast we're here to talk about life
problems drugs accomplishments and
everything in between i'm your host
thomas dopasiola whatever you want to
call me marty is here we are yo yo it's
a no guest episode all right these are
my favorite things to do so
um i love talking to people but i kind
of like talking to marty best
i mean we're just gonna be honest this
is what we do so we do yeah so this is
my favorite thing to do thank you guys
for joining us on another week this is
probably gonna be one of the last solos
for
[Music]
not one of the last solos but we have a
lot of we have a lot of guests coming
guys all right
we just hired a booking agent boom so
we're no longer
hey 60 emails we're trying to book guess
you know what i mean uh we finally got
somebody so i'm excited for that it's
going to be awesome we have a lot of
guests coming up so that's what i'm
saying uh
the month of june we had no solo podcast
not one
so i feel like the month of august this
would be the only song yeah yeah yeah
but i'm excited guys the guests that
we're trying to get
i'm [ __ ] excited you guys deserve
some real [ __ ] guests i'm [ __ ]
excited man like not that we haven't had
someone else
badass guess we're so committed to
trying to keep this thing going yes
should we talk about who we're trying to
get right now or no yeah [ __ ] might as
well so i used to have a sound guy up in
uh named tim shout out to tim from
stockton i did not realize
that he's nick diaz and diaz's cousin
he grew up with them and i talked about
them he goes hey do you want him on the
show i'll hit him up so we're working on
nate nick diaz right now working on
kevin smith stevo
uh bam's in rehab but i really want to
bam on you guys ask for joey diaz
nonstop
probably not gonna happen for a while
guys he's not coming to la any time soon
we can do a zoom one but i'm not doing a
[ __ ] zoom podcast it's not gonna
happen i'm not gonna do it um
just because it's not the same i want to
go hey joey diaz hit this i don't want
to go hey
what's that in the back of your video
like no [ __ ] that [ __ ] i want the energy
yeah we need the vibe we need to be next
to each other talking [ __ ] like that's
what i want all right so
just want to start off right there guys
with the basics all right we're working
on
a bunch of new guests all right working
on a bunch of new guests i'm very
excited for the ones to come it's gonna
be sick if you saw last week's podcast
shout out to you that was my homie
ratchet man ratchatone really good
episode i [ __ ] loved it oh yeah i
really liked the episode it was very
interesting
he crushed it i loved it um one more
thing i want to get into uh before
before we start if you're in the car
please be safe i got another dm someone
totaled your [ __ ] car listen to the
podcast i feel like we're getting one of
these every episode
please be safe man be careful dude
thankfully thankfully everyone was okay
but damn getting that dm yo finally
happened [ __ ] total my car while
listening to the podcast i was laughing
though
so was it so good that made you lose
control i don't know i'm not sure or was
it like
you're a bad driver
and you should be more
what was it you should pay more uh damn
pay more respect
just pay more attention to the road
[ __ ] dude my brains everywhere today all
right i've been
i've been busy today um real quick i
want to move into this and i won't talk
about it again
all right some of you [ __ ] all
right ready
i've been vegan for four
five years a lot of you don't know that
because i'm not a [ __ ] [ __ ] vegan
that's like you know by the way you know
what you're eating
it's [ __ ] murder yeah it's murder
people know that do you have to [ __ ]
say it all the time no you don't i like
dogs i like animals like cows i just
don't eat them i have to shove it in
your [ __ ] face
i hate people i [ __ ] hate vegan
people sometimes so i hate 98.8 of
vegans i will punch you all right
so we did uh we got on it recently all
right we got on it as a sponsorship and
you guys know that
i had a lot of backlash right had a lot
of people talking [ __ ] to me because
they sell non-vegan stuff too
so does the [ __ ] grocery store
so does my favorite pizza place and
favorite mexican
uh spot the vegan options that's why i
support him because i'm like oh you got
vegan [ __ ] thank you for looking out for
people i'll [ __ ] support it
that's like telling me
marty had the best examples like so if
we get a whole food sponsorship are
people going to talk [ __ ] because they
sell meat in the back
exactly [ __ ] you all right i know
youtube's probably gonna demonetize us
[ __ ] you
so um
we did get a ton of amazing feedback
from the commercial also oh dude i'm
only bringing up the thing because it's
like i don't want it in the there were
so many comments in the last video about
him like
and i respond to all of them i'm tired
of [ __ ] getting aggravated at people
yeah we know there's way in the pro team
it's milk i don't use that [ __ ]
that's it all right don't
they got hundreds of products so
hundreds of products only a small
portion of our viewers are actually
vegan but like it is a great for
instance we had a product come at us
that
didn't have any vegan options no options
we turned that [ __ ] down even though
they were like yeah we'll pay you right
now
[ __ ] yeah
nah i can't do it man uh you should make
vegan [ __ ] you're a health food company
[ __ ] and so i turned it down because
there's no option for me i can't
advertise something i can't actually try
or use ana's got 50 products yeah they
have trouble everything and also
there's weights
i'm not eating weights all right
well you have been lately i have been
i've been [ __ ] working out guys i've
been working out and oh real quick i
have no idea why i was trending on the
twitter the other day for boxing crazy
why the number one thing of all boxing
in the world was me lifting [ __ ]
weights
oh because there was a boxing bag in the
back it can't be it can't be i don't
know how that i thought that [ __ ] was
based on hashtags or something i didn't
hashtag anything i have no that was like
some algorithmic yes i've never trained
it on any twitter how fun you're
hilarious how funny palo people like yo
i'm looking up boxing and it's just
you're
you're fat dude just lifting weights
like yeah
good i guess that [ __ ] could have ended
up on sportscenter first throwing up
hella weight after not lifting for a
super long time we'll we'll get there
guys um and you guys really know i said
uh was it by episode 100 or episode 52
one that's a big [ __ ] difference big
difference
i'm trying to bench i'm trying to get
back over 300 by the end of the year and
i think i can do it i think i could do
it i hit 215 a bunch of times it was not
bad
but i haven't lifted since high school
so it's so cool to see everybody just
like everybody's so happy to see you
good afternoon so hype man i love you
[ __ ] guys man i love you guys you
know how many people hit me i'm like i'm
starting to like the [ __ ] yeah it's just
uh
who
how often do people start trends that
are beneficial to people in a good way
yeah not often yeah and i'm so happy
that it act i didn't wasn't trying to
i'm just trying to get hot i'm trying to
get high i'm trying to get shape and not
fat anymore and hella fools are like
yeah me too [ __ ] yeah
i'm excited yeah i'm very excited for
sure and i mean [ __ ] a lot of kids look
up to you too and as far as annika was
like you can look at the ingredients
they use the tip top best ingredients
that could be found i also wouldn't use
this [ __ ] if it wasn't yeah like that
it's anybody wondering we've been
working this deal forever like since we
started that was the first one we're
like gotta get on it marty introduced me
and i went oh [ __ ] this is everything
they do [ __ ] yeah he's been to their
campus and
anyway i just want to get off it off my
chest guys um
i love everyone's opinion when they're
nice
all right i value your opinion very
highly when you're nice
when people are slightly rude to me
because i'm super nice but when people
are slightly rude to me
it's cr
if they knew how little i gave a [ __ ]
they'd be offended it's just when if
somebody's trying to be shitty on some
petty [ __ ] like oh i caught you in
something i got caught you guys
oh [ __ ] we know there's [ __ ] weight
on your goddamn protein that's why it's
over there and i don't use this [ __ ]
it's for product placement [ __ ]
[ __ ] you anyway uh
you guys already know me i don't give a
[ __ ] you can suck two dicks i do not
give a [ __ ] about your opinion if you're
not nice but if you're nice we do care
about your opinion and updates on the
show get this guess get that guess we
listen when it's nice
but if you have a
valid argument i'll talk to you i'm not
just saying oh you disagree with me [ __ ]
you that's not what i'm saying if you're
a little [ __ ]
you can eat a dick
sorry for the the rough the rough intro
the demonetization intro i'm very sorry
i said [ __ ] 62 times because people suck
dicks twice
per breath so i think we're not
monetized on this one which is fine
because i'm getting [ __ ] up this
episode
um
guys what time is everybody how long
have been 11 30. yes
uh i just picked up some [ __ ]
weed all right i just bought some
[ __ ] oh i just dropped a joint
oh
out of reach good thing i have them
rolled i'll pick another another one
there's a really fat joint down there
rosie please don't let me don't let me
forget no no you're good
it's really that was the fattest one
damn it okay i'm gonna smoke this joint
guys before i do that i want to get into
some fan questions this is something we
want to incorporate more
but real quick i just want to say
i asked on our right here boom dope as
usual podcast this is our instagram
right
check out our instagram
you high-ass people
you guys are higher than i am i asked
hey people send me uh send us questions
for the podcast and we'll put you in the
podcast today but send us in video form
like yo what's up guys and send the
video
i've gotten three videos out of like 30.
everyone else is high as [ __ ] just text
me like bro i said send a video so i can
put your your face on the show the main
point is we want to do a little more fan
interaction on the show
[ __ ] how many orders did we get
this week with no zip code i'm pissed
all right answer your emails or push
trees guys you know how many times
you've gotten peep
i did a giveaway and the guy sent me his
whole address and he bugged me where's
it at and i go bro i've been hitting you
up you didn't leave a city
or state
[Music]
any town usa any town usa or some
citizenship one two three fake street
that's what they did to me so
you guys are high all right next time
we're gonna do it more we'll give you
more more time to prep but we want to
include you guys in the podcast more
because i see you guys in the chat all
[ __ ] day as uh i i can't remember
names i only remember the first couple
letters and then the uh picture so i see
the same people in the chat like right
now
evo e v okay evoking
uh a s o dolphin or something like that
maddie b we in here ev i see you guys
you know that right i see you guys every
damn week in the chat non-stop i [ __ ]
appreciate it if i didn't say your name
it's not that i don't like you it's just
i can't remember every name all right
so thank you guys i just want to say
thank you guys so much so this is us
trying to incorporate you guys a little
bit all right so we're gonna start off
with these questions fan questions let
me like this giant
guys the very first question is from
oh [ __ ] what's his name at the top
it's the one i sent the full picture to
sorry guys uh i had to screenshot
everybody because they didn't send
videos so i just screenshot it uh what
is it
martin garcia martin garcia what's up
martin garcia's question and this is a
question i get
every day
would you ever have your dad or your
sister on the podcast
my dad
was a super bad alcoholic i don't like
to have him around triggers
i guess you would say
you know like he doesn't smoke weed at
all i mean i can do a no weed podcast of
course i can i've smoked weed around my
damage at my house i'm not going to not
smoke weed
because he's fine with it we had a great
weedless episode of fabian exactly we
could do a weedless episode it's just my
dad is a truck driver
and he'll shoot you in the face i just
don't want someone like oh you're is
that oh you're so-and-so is to enter at
a raw or do something weird cause my
doubt kill your ass i don't want my dad
going to prison over somebody on the
podcast
do you see him i didn't think you were
gonna take it there well i mean people
are weird
that's why i don't show my my mom i
didn't show my mom for the first seven
years of instagram because she does
nails
and has a shop i don't want people
walking up in there my mom [ __ ] you up
too
that's all that's why i don't show my
little brother
people are [ __ ] creeps
so anyway i would show my dad i would
have him on the show
my dad's very offensive all right he
thinks things are funny that are super
[ __ ] offensive
so i don't want my dad out here
canceling me
but no my dad would be a great episode i
just don't know what to talk to his ass
about he's such a goof like in a good
way he's gonna constantly be [ __ ]
with me
i don't it's hard to talk to my dad like
how do i so dad tell me about f he
started telling me about
something in high school once i went dad
stop
no more
stop talking right now bro i was like 17
he told me how he sold a girl to some
gang bangers so they can get an 8-ball
chris
my dad would you say he's like so some
girl and he explained it to me
[ __ ] do my sisters and [ __ ] watch ain't
[ __ ] it's our dad all right
[ __ ] i'll blame my uncle behind me it's
my dad and all behind me
all right so my the story is my tea see
i'm just telling a quick story he's
gonna do a five-hour podcast
so my dad was uh very very good-looking
in high school like he was in shape and
the wrestling team was a good-looking
[ __ ] right
let's just say he was pulling [ __ ]
all the time all right that's one of my
mom's big things about hey can you stop
cheating on me like dad that's a very
reasonable request
can you just stop or break the [ __ ] up
mom you're also stupid for knowing and
just oh it's fine we'll punch each other
in the face
smoke some meth and get over it
option [ __ ]
and i know my mom's in the chat too yeah
mom i know you're in the chat thanks for
the donations too by the way she's been
cause i've been giving her all this
[ __ ] gear let me buy him like mom i'm
not gonna charge that i'm just gonna
keep donating she's our number one
supporter though mom
i appreciate it but damn that's why i
gave it to you for free so you don't
spend money
um
so my dad was uh with my behind me they
were doing coke all night he said this
white girl was in love with my [ __ ]
dad like in love with my dad but he's
like
she just wasn't really my type but mom
behind me is a dirt ball so he's like oh
she's my type
so he was like messing around with her
they're all getting on one they went to
some party
and it was in merced on 12th street so
it was gangbangerland
so they said they're at a party and some
of the gang banger fool they're all just
chilling because my dad knows them
and he said like yo what's up with this
chick like she's kind of like all over
the place like can i bang her basically
and they're like no that's like like
she's with us and he says so like so
what is it going to take can i bang her
not like can i rape this girl it's more
of like yo she's being kind of wild out
here like is this your girl can i take
her to the she was being very open
mm-hmm right
and she was gonna bang this guy whether
or not my dad was like cool
no but my dad and he's like so in my
head i go that's not my girlfriend she
looks like she's she's all over the
[ __ ] dude i'm gonna be like so this
is my dad say so so my plan was
train me an 8-ball
and i'll just leave her here
so my dad got an 8-ball chris and walked
out of the place and left left that girl
there damn not like he left her to die
she was ready to bang that dude anyway
and he goes
yeah trade me an april you got like a
consolation prize that's exactly what
happened and i i it's disgusting
it's so that's someone's daughter bro
that's [ __ ] up that's [ __ ] up she's
probably on meth today
sure that's not his fault it's not his
fault but also like did you just sell a
woman dad [ __ ]
i think cell is a tough problem
nah we're gonna leave there's a lot of
dudes here she might be in danger but
also she was like
my dad was basically skidding and she's
like she was like taking her clothes off
like draining around on this doom damn
[ __ ] there for the streets she was best
yeah yes but i mean my dad got a free
[ __ ] 180 buck and he's 60 bucks out
of it that's not easy to do that's the
real like that's that real quick
chris eighth that's a good negotiator
that's true huh is he gonna negotiate
yeah shoot on the debate team i mean
he's dealing with some [ __ ] game
bangers they're surprised they weren't
like nah my dad my dad was and my uncle
they're all f
if you're from merced and you grow up i
grew up all gangbangers i'm not a gay
man like i know them they're cool i go
to their parties and like i know i'm not
getting shot by them at least because
you know i'm cool with them that's
probably what my dad was doing but uh
maybe i'll have my dad on the show
he can tell us yeah
maybe i'll have him on the show
as for my sister my sister's a [ __ ]
[ __ ] i don't think i can
sit there for 40 minutes and go hey
i have this on video
this is what happened
look and she's gonna go no it's not you
[ __ ] idiot i go but [ __ ]
it's on [ __ ] video you're on the
video saying it
it's not me
what sound effect are you doing oh that
you're doing a sound effect
that's my sister i can't i can't do it
can't do it
she look at this way if she was nice i'd
be all right but she's very negative and
i was like i can't do that it's gonna be
tough to keep going i was at the [ __ ]
memorial this weekend and there was like
six seconds away
i'm too old to punch you in the mouth
but i might
i'm not kidding she had a beer and i was
thinking where would she fall if i smack
his [ __ ] whatever i did the whole thing
in my head and went
off of something newer this is just old
[ __ ] dude
i was at this memorial like [ __ ] be
nice um i can't take this sometimes it's
just too much that's why i don't hang
out with her that much
and she's watching this like hey just
stop being mean
[ __ ]
be nice
you don't have to disagree with
everything you [ __ ] hassle anyway
no i will not have my sister on the
podcast man i will not
maybe my dad
maybe my dad
maybe one day if you had to pick one my
dad okay
i bet he's got crazy stories that's a
wild [ __ ] he's going to keep you
on your heels a little bit i've never
met your dad i've never heard him but
that's [ __ ] cool
and he's been driving for 40 years
almost um he's been driving he's about
nine he bit a dude's face off get a
dude's face
a lot of [ __ ] my dad uh
i can't even get into it there's a lot
i'll just leave it at that there's a lot
my dad's doing some stupid [ __ ]
martin garcia's out his name was
i think so i think it was martin garcia
i feel like the last name yeah wrong hey
martin garcia big jersey thank you so
much that's a nice chair you got there
all right uh can we go on to the next
question thank you very much
this is
rodrick805 thank you this is from
instagram are you a fan of the ufc
if so
do you have a favorite fighter
great question okay so if when it comes
to podcasting i feel like every comedian
is like yo i love ufc why i have no
[ __ ] idea because
okay that's what it is okay oh yeah he's
the usc guy i'm a [ __ ] idiot oh god
i mean no that's it's not cuz of rogan
but that's the effect he he put ufc in
podcasting i'm so [ __ ] dumb okay take
it back
so you know how you [ __ ] comedians
really like ufc right
um
i stopped watching it the second i
got to college i think the second i
wasn't home all the time
you know you know what i'm saying
i was out doing [ __ ] i wasn't at home
watching ufc i wasn't doing that anymore
but i used to be act i used to watch ufc
i used to rent them from blockbuster you
see one all the way through six me and
my dad would rent them and wait a couple
months
and rent them again because back then
there was no streaming i went to
blockbuster
um
me and my dad used to bet nickels and
dimes on matches it's before weight
classes remember veto belfort
hit vanderley silva not family silva
come on
ball head dude
ball head dude real [ __ ] up
cauliflower ears it's [ __ ] all of
them i know but he uh he does the axe
kick he's famous for the [ __ ]
downward axe kick bald dude uh come on
man he kind of looks like blanca uh
baraka from mortal kombat
this is a hell of a description come on
man you know what it is it's when
vandalized still uh uh vito belfort
[ __ ] his [ __ ] up in like ufc six or
something like gotcha we're about to
pull him he's like 18 years old dude
it's his most famous one where he hits
the fool all the way across the ring and
knocks his ass asleep randy curve tour
nope i don't know randy couture
vandalism van der ley silva i said
anderson silva
vanderlei
he looks like the dude for the teeth and
the swords in his hands from mortal
kombat
that's what he looks like damn you got a
facelift oh [ __ ]
oh wow i haven't seen him in a minute
yeah vandalism anyway me and my dad were
betting when that fool was like coming
up kicking fools in the face mm-hmm so
i've been watching ufc all my whole life
because you're like your team frame of
reference to the ufc is like
when i started learning this about you
so much earlier than mine because i
didn't become a fan of the ufc until
like after all that so it's interesting
because i know nothing about what you're
talking about with it and like you don't
know about it's the post like mark
coleman's yeah yeah i never watched any
of those i go back and watch them now
who was it who's a
is it ken shamrock frank shamrock's
little brother that kicked mark coleman
in the [ __ ] mouth and knocked his ass
asleep
me and my dad watched that tape like 60
times
because he was like a dollar or two more
to [ __ ] rent from blockbuster an
extra day you know what i mean that's
insane that you were renting these shits
from [ __ ] blocks all day all day dude
we would random all the [ __ ] no dvd
there's mark coleman
mm-hmm oh this was the dude that uh did
you see the vid hold on
marcom's beast oh it's a goddamn video
video game
that's how good video games are shout
out to ufc video game all right i
thought that was a real fight right now
watching video game
ufc gameplay is matt hughes okay
there matt hughes is the was the [ __ ]
man destroy the [ __ ] out of everybody
you can't touch his ass
he was he was the man you see him now
bro
see what happened to him
uh
i in my mind he like something bad
happened to you break his spine
and he like talked
he's like trying to talk like his
brain's not functioning i didn't realize
it was so [ __ ] sad like from being
the all-american
[ __ ] badass wrestler the only fool
that used to [ __ ] his [ __ ] up was george
st pierre
remember the battles they used to have
dude i think he beat george st pierre
once or george champion swept his ass
three times i can't remember there it is
picture georgetown matthews um
that's my era i was on it because uh
marvin beastman eastman
is from merced and my one of my best
friends anthony that's uncle so when i
first walked in anthony's house marvin
beastman eastman answered the door bro
the first thing he says like got a deep
ass voice for a little boy
yeah all right man thanks
marvin beast there's the cut there's the
cup vito belfort ripped his [ __ ] eye
off look at that cut it's the worst cut
in ufc history until that point that's
marvin beastman eastman my best friend i
used to be my best friend justin eastman
mm-hmm uh remember i told you about my
step-dad and my my neighbor my best
friend his dad
was the sh like the cop
his little brother is him
marvin eastman's older brother is a cop
in merced and he's like six six four
rocked i saw him revving 440 driving his
feet up with coach and coach scheidt the
piece of [ __ ] from football looks just
like matthews
i mean he looks just like matt hughes
it's kind of annoying
anyway
i can't just keep my brain focused matt
hughes is my favorite ufc fighter all
right that's a legendary answer he's a
[ __ ] badass
so yes stop right there yeah we got to
get we got a
it was fun watching the ufc last time a
lot oh dude i didn't realize that
was sean o'malley yeah i didn't realize
that what a monster we didn't he was we
i we were setting the [ __ ] fight up
it took us the whole we missed and then
we missed the mystifier
afterwards
god damn sean o'malley this is oh he
[ __ ] psycho would not stop for
charging forward for everyone that
watched it
the other train
that was him his [ __ ] train non-stop
bro he was punching the guy in the face
have you ever seen the movie sin city
uh no
for everyone out there seeing sin city
remember rap bastard the guy that was
the rapist with the the yellow dude
that's what the fool's face looked like
after that sean o'malley got beat the
[ __ ]
it was lumpy and nasty and [ __ ] just
like that i've never seen somebody not
go down yeah like why won't you die why
won't you die i was hitting him with
everything he had looking like what the
[ __ ] oh he was
taking his [ __ ] head off and the guy
was like that
eat it eat it eat it more please
who is that whoever that is is going to
be a [ __ ] monster i hope we get him
in here to get sean in here to ask him
about that because he's next time he's
in l.a we locked him in yeah right as
far as i know yeah he's coming in but
what were you thinking like what did you
get
that's a good question like did you at
all go full for real cause you gotta
feel it in your hands like when you
catch somebody like boop he's going no
you know and he how sad must it be like
it's like a dream when you punch
somebody in the face and they're like
are you gonna hit me yeah my [ __ ] man
how come i just can't kill you in my
dream and i know a lot of you went me
too you're punching through water yep
like that yep yeah but that's where yeah
that anyway i think i could see you
getting back into it and i could see
that for sure yeah yeah that's sure
i mean it's it's what's more intense
than the before while they're walking
into the cage
because i used to wrestle dude i used to
play football and i miss the
coming out and staring down whoever i'm
going against like i'm gonna [ __ ]
kill your ass
it's that intense like
[Music]
i don't know what it is it's something
about like football furthers you play
football coming out on the field it's
just like uh-huh
man i remember when we were in college
that they'd do the bring them out bring
them out we never
damn dude i really never had music come
out
what what'd you guys do oh you just ran
through the [ __ ] paper yeah
all right
yourself sucks all right where's that
[ __ ] sucks we didn't have [ __ ]
i played for a [ __ ] fight
you guys
at least
at least bro at least gonna hit us with
the [ __ ]
yo brian
somebody commented because i can't think
and i remember i was like i gotta do
this i do this
you should really get looked at blah
blah blah
no i don't give a [ __ ] i'm gonna go to
the doctor and go hey your brain
functions a lot like thanks
do you want me to pay you for that
here take these bills i'm not taking the
pills
well what you do is exercise you mean
work
you mean
think about something else and focus
it's called work [ __ ]
adhd is a blessing i don't know what
anybody else says that's a [ __ ]
blessing because some of you
[ __ ] can't concentrate on one
thing i'm too six at once it might be
only ten percentage yeah and then i
circle back and knock them all out but i
will [ __ ] knock them off done though
they will get done
um
yeah so leave it at that matt hughes all
right dude i can't answer a question oh
[ __ ] that [ __ ] huge i'm interested to
see if the ufc has any more superstars
coming up though for sure i mean it's
coming it's coming
i'm telling you dude
people now that they realize like how
much did the kid make
i'm gonna start fighting you know how
many natural monsters there are out
there that don't understand they're
[ __ ] monsters i just can't wait i
just love seeing the fat mexican dude
win like uh
what was the one that just won the the
world championship boxing come on
the big mexican kid i don't know think
about boxing there was a pretty fat
mexican dude in ufc that was just
beating somebody's ass i was watching i
just liked kane velasquez [ __ ] full
has brown pride tatted on his body like
oh my god and it doesn't say him uh diaz
right wow that's [ __ ] up when you come
up fat mexican boxer google search
dude
world champ yeah oh no i know this dude
he's on rogan yeah i know [ __ ] [ __ ]
champion dude yeah i mean that's badass
man that's one of those fighting is one
of those things where it's like the body
type might not be what that body type is
i work construction in merced
also i drink beers
yeah you got to remember that next time
you're out talking [ __ ] somebody at the
bar
it might be him it might be someone just
like cinder block strength 115 every day
out there
yeah yes
people don't understand dude people
don't get it
anyway
i can't keep on topic matt hughes okay
can we go back to the [ __ ]
to the questions please
all right next question guys here we go
this is from good evening cuddy it's a
great name do you like any indie music
mac demarco or tyler the creator people
that
people like that alternative music if
you will okay
i don't really think tyler creator's
alternative anymore i think he's pop he
went pop he's 100 on every radio station
love
loved uh
the golf wang stuff i went to me and
rosie our first
time going to a show uh besides the murs
one was
uh
tyler the credit's where i wanted to go
i'm like oh you know what odd future
shit's pretty tight
and i went mac demarco you ever heard of
mac demarco no great he's great i really
[ __ ] with it he has a video
people don't realize that a music video
can make you transcend generations and
they don't get it some people are still
still throwing up money in front of a
rented car
they don't get it yet this [ __ ]
mac demarco i think it's
my kind of woman this fool is literally
just dressing up as a chick from start
to finish in the whole song and it's so
[ __ ] good
people don't appreciate things
it's [ __ ] art all right i love
the guy his his music's really good dude
nice like on some missed out fire type
[ __ ] like no he's it's like a
cross-dresser it's yeah yes
yes i i kind of like it as a uh what's
that song um lola remember that song
oh that old ass 60s song lola was
talking about he's
he meets a chick but it turns out to be
a dude he didn't ever met a
ah
the kings thank you the kinks
that's what that kind of vibe gives me
like
it's a good [ __ ] song talking about
some wild [ __ ] i [ __ ] with that
i know
i don't know like
[ __ ] with that dude heavy heavy heavy i
know a lot of people are always
surprised when i say it but bro i've
been watching rupaul's drag race so
[ __ ] heavy and i'm down to the damn
all-stars and i'm bored
down to the all-star i just love seeing
dudes that got picked on their whole
[ __ ] life come out and shine so
[ __ ] hard doing what they like and
it's like that full just did the splits
on heels [ __ ] you can't even do that
[ __ ] [ __ ] you talking [ __ ] that's a
grown man he's six six doing splits [ __ ]
you i just think it's cool i think it's
[ __ ] i think it's awesome man
you have to remember all those gages got
beat up as kids like all got [ __ ] with
and now they're like looked up to and
[ __ ] i i like it it's it's pretty
[ __ ] cool
i'm just over the [ __ ] challenges
i skipped some of the challenges i'm
like just get to the end bro get to the
[ __ ] dance lip sync for your life
[ __ ] already [ __ ] i've never heard you
bring this up before i [ __ ] i love
rupaul's dragon i just i just love
seeing fools do what they like mm-hmm
you know what i mean because
most people like who are these gay-ass
fools like [ __ ] you
there's more girls for you now they
don't like girls
that's the one thing i i never got like
oh it's gay fool like probably ain't
bugging you oh if he hits on me are you
gay
nothing's gonna happen then stupid
is the average dude still yes kind of
like that yes and i have a lot of
friends that are very very homophobic
and i check them and i make fun of them
that's my favorite [ __ ] i love jackie i
i won't say your name's justin i will
see you
i got some homies that are like
they're not homophobic but they're more
like what was it a
kevin hart's bit
i don't want my son to be gay it's not
like i'm mad at it but if i could choose
him not to be i would be he would a lot
of people like that and i get that i
guess i get that because you're like oh
i want kids i want grandkids i would
totally choose for my daughter to be
lesbian if i could oh that's your
daughter though bro that's your dog i've
already decided this yes 13 year old
going through all this [ __ ]
yeah don't get pregnant please just
don't get [ __ ] right god life would
be so much easier yeah not to worry like
yo any point in time there could be me a
grandpa starting
oh
no thank you
could you imagine
there's girls in merced right i mean i
won't name names i know
i know 30 year old grandmothers
i've met 32 year old grandmas and 40
[ __ ] five-year-old great-grandmas
yeah it's called catholicism
uh isn't that catholic [ __ ] that's
called oh you can't have birth control
and [ __ ] but uh you know our priests
they might you know let's just not get
into this [ __ ] let's just not get into
this let's just leave it at that back to
marco mac demarco let's go back to music
yes i love alternative music i [ __ ] with
the heavy all right there we go let's go
to the next question
i would need my dad to give me [ __ ]
trouble then again
[ __ ] those fools yeah [ __ ] creeps
child molester [ __ ] but they got money
and i wanted to shut down our [ __ ] so uh
who's that too
my bad
i guess is there another question
if you could okay yeah from dash
swerving
if you could go back to college what
would you do differently finish
ready
next question that is the all i have to
say about that i would just finish you
know i do got to say
my cousin melissa is a professor at
merced college right
i am i'm only one class away from my aaa
degree
i'm one [ __ ] class away from my
that's pretty insane i was just done i'm
damn i don't like algebra two
all right
once you miss one day you're [ __ ]
it's like building an engine you missed
the first day go so where are we at oh
we're on the carburetor well i'm walking
that's me bro like i'm done i guess
so i have an idea
and it's called dobazilla goes back to
college
and what i'm thinking is i go back to
school i film it i sit in class for one
day and then i take the rest of it
online
because i don't want to be around a
bunch of [ __ ] people anymore
also i pay somebody to take my class
online i ain't doing that [ __ ] they
could do [ __ ] face swap or whatever
they want i am not sitting there and
going to class that's the reason i
didn't finish i don't [ __ ] care but i
think it'd be good to go you know what i
got my degree
in
general business i guess as long as like
if you're just [ __ ] paying for that
[ __ ] like that's really what it is it's
like a moral victory to finish it i
think i think it's more of like this
like in your position finished for you
for the average person [ __ ] finish it
i mean because i i know like people in
my family going for their [ __ ]
big time degrees and they end up gassing
out on the last thesis my uh
then you just got that debt and you got
nothing to show for it god damn i did
the same thing yeah somebody asked me
that on the live the other day like
because you don't know what the [ __ ] you
want to do or what you're good at where
your strengths are
business because like it's universal
yeah start [ __ ]
oh the reason i brought up my cousin
melissa is because i was going to ask
her to
help me cheat
hey can you just like
give weed to the alpha teacher do you
and i asked her
the way i kind of leaned to it was like
hey
do teachers like hang out and get [ __ ]
up together like i think they do she
goes no
[ __ ] man that was like i'm done all
right then you don't know i'm just gonna
leave it at that i'm not gonna even ask
you to just
risk your [ __ ] job
but risk your job
i'm kidding i'm kidding
kinda
maybe i'll just go to like the burbank
college or something
just go i mean but i also don't want to
be going and going yo what up yo what
i'm like bro
yeah i'll smoke with you later i'm
actually trying to study because you
imagine you go i can't i can't for the
first two years i did instagram i was
still going to school
and um
no thanks
if i really can't study i in concentrate
i really won't be able to concentrate
with people like yo what up bro like yo
i follow you like thanks man [ __ ] yeah
you could you i just missed the whole
step [ __ ] quadratic formula's gone
you gotta bang it out online that's what
it is i'm gonna pay somebody to do it
and for the shots go so today
and it clips in like some bad movies a
different person
yeah i'm not i'm not doing school [ __ ]
you maybe in 10 years or something dude
honestly i hate feeling [ __ ] out at
doctor's places like oh [ __ ] you
couldn't have just asked me
and filled this out i got it
[ __ ] oh yeah slash could you imagine
slash we need you to thomas we need you
to come in and go to the registrar's
office and then head over to admissions
never doing roundup again i ain't ever
gonna get my books again i'm not waiting
the line again i'm not going unless
you're building i ain't doing that you
don't want to buy a couple thousand
dollars worth of books and then don't
use them and then have them give you 50
cents back
from merced with no money we get paid to
go to college
we get financial hey
we don't pay for [ __ ] and then as soon
as you're one month in you don't go back
and you keep your check because you went
long enough
merced for the first three weeks is
packed and then the start of the fourth
week there's nobody left it was always
the best like oh cool i'll have seats on
monday these people are gone they're out
as soon as they get the financial they
check
[Music]
them i guess i guess do you think was
the last question
yeah that's the last one we got picked
out okay all right thank you um
how long are we at 35
please don't tell me longer 42.
all right
i'm trying to do an hour and a half
so um i didn't spark the joint oh my god
you dropped the one and then [ __ ] it i
dropped the ball
that's what happened um okay here we go
here we go here we go
so let's start talking all right today's
gonna be a little different
i'm gonna go straight stories till this
is over
okay today's a different day
light this joint up for everybody
driving i'm just lighting a joint oh i'm
so burnt marty
i just went like this
again my god damn
we gotta make a logo out of that you
[ __ ] i put the joint in my ear before
when i was picking my phone have you
ever done that i've gone like that
[ __ ] idiot i've done that many times
the one time i got really high really
high at work when i worked at mcdonald's
i closed the burger to and i threw it on
the grill and closed it and then i threw
the [ __ ] frozen patty into dunn
hamburgers like a dumb ass didn't
realize for five minutes i went back and
shit's on fire
[ __ ] eating
dumb
but yeah you know stuff happens
i don't know how or why but when i lit
this up and i smell the smoke come off i
just smell pure cocaine
i don't know why unless you put some
cocaine in there no i didn't
somebody's trying to get you in that rap
could you imagine lacing the papers with
gotcha
that's actually kind of amazing it would
be awesome in another life i remember
one time we got some weed from this dude
my boy is breaking it down he's like
he said it so casually uh we got to kill
this [ __ ]
i'm like what it's like release the
[ __ ] weed
and he started like pulling the weed
apart and i don't know if it was like
lint or what the [ __ ] was in the weed
but what he lays it with he didn't lace
it with anything it was like just some
[ __ ] matter i don't know what the
[ __ ] it was
yeah really small pulled it off the weed
uh
spider webs yeah that's happened i've
gotten nuggs like that where my oh bro
i'll never buy away from this guy again
[ __ ] yeah i've never seen some [ __ ] like
that oh i've seen some rot
you were telling me about that people
get lung infections and [ __ ] from that
trait yeah
that's why i'm so picky now
um
all right here we go let's start off i'm
avoiding but we're good it
so today is august 3rd 2021.
if you guys were my
fans from a long time ago you have
watched story time one season three is
story time right
and the person that comes up more than
anybody on the planet in my story times
obviously is my uncle john you guys
already know that
um
uncle john was a [ __ ]
super [ __ ] cool he's only 10 years
older than i am so when i say uncle
he's my
my blood aunt it's her husband
so you know he he comes in the family
he's not related to anybody
we're like 10 11 me my sister
it's my uncle john like he's cool uncle
john's cool he's [ __ ] hilarious
i'll tell you the first time i met him i
went to the gold's gym i went to gb3
and my aunt introduced me to some guy
she wasn't dating him but i remember i
looked at him like
you're your chops look like saber tooth
because he had like these big chops just
like sabertooth from eggs man he goes
it does look like sabertooth
i liked him right away that was it
all right they started dating got
married the rest is history right
so that's my uncle 10 or 11 right
so you guys heard him in story time all
the [ __ ] time because when i got
older we started doing some drugs all
right we started that was my friend that
was like my older brother and tis august
3rd
and exactly a year ago he passed away
and he passed away very young he's only
41.
um
so yeah today's a year
weird days a year
it doesn't feel like a year at all
in any way shape or form
[Music]
i still almost text his ass all the time
and i remember he's not here anymore so
today is going to be
diving into uncle john [ __ ] all right
it's going to be really cool and before
i start
you guys already know the story times
all right
that was my partner like that was my
homie that we got [ __ ] up i ditch he
picks me up we get [ __ ] up he dropped
me off a sixth period i pretend that i
was at school all day do it all over
again all right so
that was
he was like my older brother man he
bought me all my [ __ ] like johnny give
me beer
oh cool here's money thanks and if i was
going with my homies he was
he was just that guy he always helped me
out i got him hooked on coke which was
the funniest thing ever i was a [ __ ]
16 years old as my grown man i got him
hooked on coke
it wasn't funny but it was funny all
right um
so before we start i feel it's only
right guys
this is what we used to drink you should
drink mickey's 40s but apparently
burbank doesn't sell 40s or something so
i only got grenades
i don't drink beer anymore i haven't
drank beer since the last time i chilled
with my uncle john i don't drink beer at
all
so
i'm gonna crack it
mickey's 40 from uncle john everybody
out there smoke one pour it up
um
yeah
shout out to john
and a little bit out
there you go
not to be sad sorry
um
yeah i haven't drank in mickey's in
years oh jacob mickey's the day he died
i went and bought one immediately
i stole my dad's little last little bit
of his stash when he died it's [ __ ]
awesome oh
this just brought me back to the shed
doing coke in the shed drinking beer
because it's hot
outside
doing the coke in the shed with no air
and no light
handle oh god
on a cd or a dvd
i don't even know what to compare that
to
fun
fun time
sorry i know this is slow sorry for
everybody driving here we go
i drink a little bit of this
ah [ __ ] mickeys
i've never even heard of that before
mickey's mm-hmm
seems like some irish [ __ ] i should know
about yeah that's a [ __ ]
i haven't drank it
like i said since the day he died and
before that since high school
so as i said before i'm gonna keep it
right here my uncle john passed away
exactly a year ago
the reason i'm bringing it up guys is uh
i haven't talked about it at all
it's naughty it's
i don't know i don't know when i was
gonna talk about it all right so today's
the day i decided you know what [ __ ] it
it's been a year
let's talk about his ass
because i talked about him before but
not after so here we go
he was the i you know i have fans i have
support my mom texts me and [ __ ] i get
that i understand
but the second my videos were over man
guys the second my videos were over my
uncle john was texting me yo that was a
good one today because
he's a merced just chilling i moved away
i was really one of the only people he
chilled with
it was my when i left i even told rose
like we got to find somebody for john to
chill with because i don't want him just
sitting here by himself just
bored you know what i'm saying like he's
not he doesn't talk to a lot of people
so i knew when i left i moved away like
it's one person i got to come back i got
him when i left the person i used to get
we from i had him start hooking him up
and then i would help him out with other
things so he would hook my uncle up with
like cheap weed like we cheaper than
normal just just to help out you know i
mean like i'm not there smoking weed
with them we used to play madden all the
[ __ ] time come over smoke bowls
you guys have that friend and my friend
just happened to be married to my aunt
that's it it was my friend and mercedes
the person i chilled with the most
it's weird to say that actually but
yeah he was the person i chilled with
the most all right
and uh it was very
it was fun it was a lot of fun man and
uh i'm gonna take you through a story of
my uncle my uncle's name was john
strange i know it's a weird last name
but yes the actual word strange is my
uncle
so let's talk guys here we go
i know it's a long intro but
i met him i told you at the gym
all the stuff hanging out i remember
when he proposed to my aunt i'm in the
i'm right there like i remember
everything i remember everything i
remember the day told us
that they're gonna have a baby
my little cousin memphis was born my
second day of high school my uncle went
and signed me out of school i remember
he had [ __ ] boots on bald head they
[ __ ]
try trash joe deer it comes in all white
trashy like that he had that like beard
lineup
he rocked a a
lint biscuit red hat fred durst it said
it was lint biscuit lb it was a real
olympus get he wore it so much
but i owe a lot to that [ __ ]
because
99 of the movies you guys hear me talk
about he showed me
like my mom showed me a lot but he
showed me
almost every one of my favorite movies
all of them every one of them
i can't think of
somebody that's shown me more [ __ ] my
whole life like any movie name like wait
that's john like oh all evil deads i was
a kid that's john all the boondocks
saying stuff
everything all the old 70s black
exploitation movies my uncle john was
the black was a white dude bald head
the biggest fan of 70s black cop and or
ninja movies
black exploitation [ __ ] you know that
that genre yeah he had all of the dvds
every [ __ ] one of them and every time
i go in you want to watch jd's revenge
again like no i don't want to watch it
again john it's the 60th [ __ ] time
you've played it all right put it on
yeah i mean like once we're warriors uh
bronson he showed me all the uh romper
stomper all the abstract like [ __ ] that
i wouldn't have saw without somebody
that was in andrew nicotina he's the
first person to ever show me on janice
katina looney corleone the loonies he's
the first person to show me all that
music right
so
all my favorite [ __ ] came from him which
is odd to think about i never really
thought about until like i'm starting to
say this [ __ ] like no you would have
different favorite [ __ ] a hundred
percent i listened to the radio when i
was a kid i would have had a different
life
for sure if i didn't go
go to school or go get [ __ ] with my
uncle john and going to get [ __ ] up is
where i got all these stories from and
where i got all this path of like i'm
just going to sell packs
like no i don't really like school i'm
signed out anyway if you sign me out
like about
i'd have a different life i'd have a way
different life and uh
i wouldn't say better maybe i'd be like
at some company but i don't want to be a
no company
i'm out of company
yeah
anyway when i got a little older guys
if i remember the first time he smoked
me with me
the very first time he was like
my sister you guys know she's a [ __ ]
dick and her and my uncle were [ __ ]
close
but i'm the little piece of [ __ ] little
brother my sister doesn't like but i'm
the one that's like a nice person my
uncle knows that he's like thomas is
fine you just don't like him he's really
nice
my uncle probably shouldn't be smoking
with me i was 21 he was 21 i was 14. no
no he was 23 i was 13 when i first
smoked a bolt
yeah i was in ninth grade
and uh first person i ever smoked salvia
with
damn is [ __ ] bug get out of here
first person i ever smoked salvia with
was him
he's the one that saved my ass my sister
was trying to stab me to death remember
when she broke my playstation uncle john
lived next door this fly oh it's
attracted to the mickey's i poured out
[ __ ] you get out of here um
[ __ ] sorry this episode's starting to
get all sidetracked
um
anyway about 14 i started hanging out
with him 13 and started hanging out with
them on a not
oh family level you know what i mean
like all right uh grandma wants to do
this he's the first person to show me
grand theft auto
and grand theft auto came part three and
he goes press circle i did it so i press
a and i punch somebody in the face and i
have been hooked
ever since
i was walking down the side street right
by the pier or the ocean part right
there in gta 3. or it was the ocean
i can't remember
i remember where it's at i know what it
looks like but the camera with the ocean
is [ __ ] irrelevant anyway
i punched somebody in the face went no
way this is what this is a video game
i've been hooked remember vice city came
out
he walked up he had a copy
he goes i got it i go oh
damn i really want to play and he goes
don't worry
that's yours i gotta buy city coffee he
gave me i'm like no [ __ ] way and
michael jackson billy jean was playing i
was on the motorcycle
i remember the whole day me and him
played for five days straight and uh
he just he was cool man he was cool when
i got a little older smoking weed he was
like wait you smoke weed
so now because he doesn't talk to people
he doesn't have homies he does
my uncle john is the funniest guy ever
if you know him and if you know him he's
super cool but if you don't know he's
not going to talk to you he will not
talk he just he's
very
he's an introvert
but when he went to the army he broke
out of that so when he came back he was
like more talkative not just to us so it
got cooler that's why when he right when
he moved back i just started dating
rosie like right when he got back dudes
so anyway sorry i'm getting sidetracked
uh
here we go so i started smoking with my
uncle john and you've heard the crack
stories and if you haven't i
accidentally i'd accidentally he loved
putting coke on top of weed
he loved it and i hated it and one time
he accidentally got some crack in this
coke and we smoked it and it was
disgusting and i [ __ ] hate it we
talked about the fabian alamo episode
[ __ ] hate crack
anyway actually i smoked crack
and in the first story times i i said
family friend i never said his name
because i didn't want him to be like yo
dude
what are you doing don't talk about that
i was stealing [ __ ] from your aunt so i
could sell it we can go get high you
didn't know that he was taking all the
dvds they had bought over the years and
just selling a couple every day and we'd
get sex i didn't know that because he
used to say
magic wallet because he'd be like i
don't have any money for any drugs today
i go ah i got like 20 bucks we can go
get weed we go get weed
and then halfway through you go don't
worry about it boom
you need to open his wall with a hell of
money in it and i go john you said you
had no money because magic wallet
he used to call it magic wallet
i don't know how he was getting money
and i found he was selling all this [ __ ]
because he was like i don't have a job
[ __ ] it um because he always worked at
richwood meets it's a place in merced
but his best friend the only friend he
ever chilled with
him and jimmy
uh this guy name there's a guy named uh
chris
and he died dude at their work
in the grinder
bro
and chris was short someone threw his
ass in damn someone someone threw his
ass in the cameras were down
some threw him in the [ __ ] me grinder
yeah bro it was real i remember when the
day it happened i smoked wee with chris
chris was cool was like oh man that's
the first time i ever choked out off of
a little bong ah snot came down he's
like dawg you'll grow into it one day
and john's laughing at me i'm like yo
i'm hanging out with the guys you know
like i was
they're barely getting 14 like [ __ ] yeah
and then chris [ __ ] died march 23rd i
remember
and uh
john stopped he never went back to work
he's like no he'll that's his best
[ __ ] homie he had to see him come out
and [ __ ] stop
yeah bro
yeah
yeah you went through the grinders in
the grinder is the thing that breaks
everything down oh so it's like a little
it's like in a track so when he came out
it was like cartoon like he got squeezed
out
it was [ __ ] up bro and they didn't
find out who did that [ __ ]
i don't want to go too much into it okay
but
someone killed him and i'll always say
that i don't give a [ __ ]
[ __ ] you
um someone killed his ass because he was
shorter than i was and i was 14. and his
six foot tall [ __ ] clearance and he
fell in [ __ ]
three short as [ __ ] anyway
uncle john is one of his only friends he
ever chill with
so
i don't even know how i got into that
story but anyway
i chill with him he didn't hang out with
anybody so when i got to like 14 15 his
homie had already gone so when he was
like oh i got someone to smoke with and
like all right because
you know because before like smoked
wheat here and there with me he wouldn't
really smoke weed with me because my
sister would always talk [ __ ] like why
you smoking with him he's [ __ ]
younger what are you doing like [ __ ]
you're a year and a half older than me
stop talking
anyway
it became a regular thing where me and
john would smoke weed i know my mom
would be at work i remember we lived
next door we touched walls our walls
connected in the apartment we were
neighbors
and our patios were right in front of
each other so i would
leave my door open and i'd walk this
door real quick five feet
walked back to my house in case my mom
came out and he'd hold it and light it
for me
but i'd walk back and just just in case
my mom came outside for some random
moment
um
and then one time my mom was at work you
guys heard this on story time i'm gonna
tell it again
the popcorn trick is from uncle john um
one time we're smoking bowls out of his
purple plastic bong ripping i've never
boxed a house i never smoked in my house
ever in my life i knew my mom was gonna
be gone for like eight more hours she
was working a double shift or some
[ __ ] she called me let me know i'm
like john she's gonna be gone for a
[ __ ] hour he goes dude what if you
smoke on the couch go
on the couch oh my god i've never smoked
weed in the house before
and uh i have but not like openly we're
fine we're chilling as a tv turn it on
smoke weed never done that
40 minutes later my mom called me and
said never mind there i'm coming home
and cancel the shift and i go oh okay
and i looked at him he goes no you're
[ __ ] lying you're [ __ ] i remember
his face dropped grown man
because my mom and him hated each other
when i was growing up because she knew
that he was [ __ ] doing drugs with us
you know which they loved each other
after but not during like those five
years
and uh he goes thomas i'm going to leave
i don't know what to do josh do not
[ __ ] leave me like this bro don't
leave me cause thomas
there's no way to get this [ __ ] smell
like i know dude what do i do my mom is
at the time i've never been caught with
anything on the ninth grade
and he goes
burn a bag of popcorn put it on for five
minutes
let it catch on fire and it'll smell
like popcorn uncle john you're a [ __ ]
genius
no no i said what if we burn popcorn he
goes yes yes yes but that's right i'm a
what if we burn popcorn it'll smell like
popcorn yeah but burn the popcorn that's
what happened i went you're a [ __ ]
genius and i got my bmx and i put it in
the middle of the [ __ ] uh living room
on its side
and then i grabbed the flaming bag and
put it on my on my spouse so it wouldn't
burn the house so i but i could leave it
smoking
i ruined the microwave guys it caught on
fire and left flames
and you know like flame burn marks and
it was all burned yellow for some of you
out there some of you guys are going
like this my microwave is burned yellow
too is it popcorn it's from popcorn it's
from leaving it in too long right it
stains the white
anyway
john and me are like doing a [ __ ]
rain dance from happiness like oh like
[ __ ] yeah it's working it because it
stunk so violent like burned popcorn
and masked out all the clowns oh yeah
damn right now you know how many i did
that on a how to hide the smell on a
video i had a hell of people like yo i
did it and it worked my mom came home
with 10 minutes and it worked because my
mom walked in with are you [ __ ]
kidding me you're burning pogo make mom
i'm sorry i thought i clicked the
popcorn but she got thomas [ __ ]
and it's so distracting you're so
irritated at your kid for being stupid
that you go
i'm sorry
oh i don't even notice the weeds yeah
and it worked and it worked and it
worked dude
so that's my uncle john uh we smoked
weed in the house right there we did
salvia right there and then on to the
next part so we move out of that area
well when my aunt and him started dating
they uh they living with us me and my
mom my sister they're living with us and
my stepdad
the prison [ __ ] they were living with us
and um
it was [ __ ] cool it was like this new
dude and you know i mean like this guy
he was hella cool he liked cool movies
my aunt's dating it was cool right and
then we moved to that spot and started
doing drugs with his ass so then let's
go 15 16.
wow what a i love this i love going
through this okay here we go awesome
15 16 years these are like some of your
best friends in life at this age like
oh yeah when you're doing this type of
[ __ ] especially if he's like your family
i could totally say that after after
school was over all we had to do was do
whatever we wanted to like oh you want
to get [ __ ] up
yep
let's get [ __ ] up then
and it was awesome
all right i'll get into that 1516
i'm doing all my stuff from story time
you guys already know i'm selling weed
he's like you're selling weed oh [ __ ] i
started selling a little bit of weed to
him and he didn't like it he was getting
weed from
john remember john from my dealers
his connect was my uncle john's connect
so in five years i would not know that i
would be buying packs directly off the
guy i was getting smoking weed from as a
little kid i didn't put that together
until i met him go wait
you know my uncle john he goes oh yeah i
won't say the other guy's name he's
piece of [ __ ] but the other guy's name
was the connect too it was just what a
small world
uh my uncle john used to work at papa
john's
i forgot to say that so in sixth sixth
grade he was the guy that dropped all
the pizza to school
so like every day because we had they
would sell pizzas at lunch time so every
day my uncle john was there i'm like
yeah it's my [ __ ] up you know when
school you see somebody you know you're
like yeah the pizza guy that's my
[ __ ] uncle and uh it was just cool
man it was cool
and he started working he was still
working at another pizza place
uh it was papa john's before it turned
into pizza guys it was papa john's and
he used to trade
pizzas for weed so he used to get called
them 80 sacks what they wore were
quarters of weed he used to get a
quarter of weed for like four pizzas and
he would give it to his connect every
friday and he would just get wheat and
that's what we would smoke all the i
mean
i was 15 16 i was smoking bowls smoking
smoking blows with him we were getting
shit-faced and then i started doing coke
when i started doing coke he got upset
with me
he
it wasn't that he was upset he was like
his thing was oh you'll never see me put
a powder at my nose and i go john then
don't i'm just putting it on the weed
though right
that was after i introduced you to
cocaine
sorry i got chronologically [ __ ]
that's why i had to back it up sorry i'm
just thinking about this fool and like
i'm not
going in order but that's i'm annoying
now so 15-16 start doing coke
had you been hiding it from him first
no
i just didn't like yo by the way i have
coke because i didn't if you guys watch
story times the first time i ever sacked
by myself
i went to my grandma's and all that
crazy [ __ ] happened where i [ __ ]
started bleeding out my face i pretty
sure i had a stroke now that everybody
tells me that
probably had a little stroke but i just
thought my whole body clenched i
couldn't feel one side of my face
and um
now i have a deviated septum but we'll
keep going uh
um
thomas you're too [ __ ] young to be
doing lines you say that stop doing
[ __ ] lines go john you just don't
know yet
and i always tell my john you of all
people would love the [ __ ] out of this
[ __ ] because thomas you're never gonna
find me putting a powder in my nose yeah
i mean he's to say all the time
as he smoked a bowl
uncle was very cool man he's cool as
[ __ ] it's i cannot believe i'm talking
about past tense right now it's so weird
still
um oh my god
and uh
one day
one day we're in the shed
just drinking smoking weed
uh my uncle didn't like to
let my aunt pepper know that he was
smoking weed with me
because i was younger so he would hide
it that's why we were always in the shed
i was just chilling with him she knew
what the [ __ ] was going on she's not
dumb
um
but he would like try to hide it as
we're always in the shed
and uh i remember one dime i had all
this i had this sack of coke am i john
i'm gonna do some lines if you want to
do one you let me know that's it because
it's like
i've explained it before i've explained
it this way and i i explained it like
this because it's how i felt do you
remember mrs doubtfire when his brother
when when robin williams goes to his gay
brother's house he goes can you make me
a woman yeah and he goes i'm so happy
that's how i felt when he goes i'll do a
line
no way like i was so happy just
chopping up lines like [ __ ] yeah
on the on the brown stool brown stool
with a soft top we put a [ __ ] case on
it
peppers
out there like [ __ ] okay
and then
it would buy candlelight because i
remember the [ __ ] click the
electricity things broke one day and we
started doing it by candlelight
dude we're just fiends just
blair witch project oh god sweating like
okay hold on hold on let me wipe all the
sweat off
hit a line it's the summer drinking
this oh gosh
130 degrees out mercedes in a shed
in the day sometimes
was the worst but at night sweating and
can't see
i have a smartphone there's no
flashlight on your phone
16 years old
there's no [ __ ] flashlight on my damn
what was it it might as well be koi it
was i don't know what it was 300 years
ago might as well have been dude and um
there's no flashlight there was an app
but i was about to bust the app out i
didn't know about it
[Music]
[ __ ] off anyway we're doing [ __ ] hell
i mean uh it's the first time i chop his
lineup right and i
i [ __ ] miss this full [ __ ]
i remember ah [ __ ]
i remember
he does it he goes like that
goes
okay i understand now i get it okay okay
i get it now michael janna i've been
trying to tell your ass
it's better than anything you've ever
done in your life goes thomas
i didn't know and he's like i didn't
know you know when like someone's like i
didn't know your dad was a beating your
ass you should have told me all those
years i didn't know
that's how him like i didn't know what i
was missing out on he didn't get it
he didn't [ __ ] get it um
and i remember his face oh
you did a lot i go oh that's it oh no
what did i do i could see coke monster
start i used to call you [ __ ] coke
monster i used to say it all the time
because
i the way i do coco is the way i smoke
weed and drink like in mass amounts i'll
do a gram line
just to [ __ ] do it just to see if i
can
and uh he's the same way
but he's
he specifically started going to jack in
the box because her straws were whiter
he's a monster he would go get a drink
and go can i get a lot of straws and
then we chop them in thirds
that was our lines cause we didn't want
to do the money because it's dirty so
we're like
that was jack in the box straws are
white as [ __ ] uh ivy dude we were
was it off to the races from that first
time you like yeah did you have to like
swindle him in that or he was just no i
said if you want to try it
because i told i told him that 38 times
yeah
and 38 sessions of smoking weed we did
and he goes no i'm good
you're too [ __ ] young to be doing
that [ __ ] you always say that you're too
[ __ ] young to be doing lines so
johnny just don't know like i said yeah
and then he did it we did the whole sag
he goes oh my god okay i get it and then
i'm pretty sure it was the next day we
got a sack together
for my friend brandon that lived three
blocks away from his house
not good yeah the coke dealer i knew was
three blocks on his same street three
blocks down one three houses in
my uncle would walk his walk with the
dogs tell my aunt go get a sack dude the
whole [ __ ] stack of white homies
he was a coke cluster and uh
i remember the dad showed him no put
some on your gums yeah what did this
turn into
drink some beer
am i teaching this whole girl man like
no what you want to do is drink the beer
after the coke goes away yeah like
john explained to his oh my god dude
drinking this is so [ __ ] weird
okay so
here we go
here comes the coke binges guys
so we started doing a lot of coke
together i'm gonna tell one story
because i love it
he lived on 24th street and he was
moving out of his house you guys have
seen cheech and chong you've seen the
ajax oh i don't know if that's ajax the
girl snorts at all we've all seen that
we've seen it cult classic
[ __ ] like that happens for real [ __ ]
happens in real life and maybe that's
why it's in movies when i talk to
charlie goes all my scenes are from life
experiences
he talks about that party
and the first time i met him john told
me about that party and how he got the
scene for the party because he met some
chicks she must have been 300 pounds
and says do you want one of these
snickers really good and then he's like
whoa that's the character in my movie
and then that's how it happened so
this is character this is a scene in my
movie and one day it'll happen all right
one time me and my uncle john all right
he's moving out of his 24th street house
my little cousin memphis is maybe two or
three he's going hard on shark boy lava
girl he's fine he's in eye distance we
take one step out the back door i wait
in the house to make sure the baby's
okay and i just yeah you good all right
cool switch then i do a line off the
washer and dryer that's right outside
then we switched and he doesn't want
another washer
the routine we never leave him by
himself because
if something happens to him we were
doing drugs we'd never be able to live
with ourselves you know what i'm saying
even though he's probably shouldn't be
doing drugs
with a baby
but he was fine he was fine
anyway
he's tall he's fine um
he's moving so
he's like yo thomas help me like pack my
house i'm like yeah of course i'll help
you he's like
cool because i got pizza and i got coke
weed and beer and go get the [ __ ] out of
here like many times he would come
through with the magic wallet i didn't
find until years later what magic wallet
was
so we're sitting there we're cleaning
we're getting all of like you know
pots and pans and
the nine tops to tupperware that you
have no bottoms to that everyone has
their [ __ ] house for some reason yeah
you find all those extra lids for colors
you've never bought
yup
yup my house right now i just found them
the other day anyway we're cleaning all
that [ __ ] out the stuff you have to go
out my back and get in the cabinets
underneath your sink and [ __ ]
that's the cabinets we're cleaning out
so we're doing the kitchen
we have this big plastic tub and i'm
putting all his cleaning supplies in one
bucket so when we get to the new house
you know i mean keep [ __ ] together i
used to work for a moving company i know
what i'm doing
and i'm trying to help him organize
that's why he's like yo help me out
so
he's got an eight ball and if you don't
know what that means it's an eighth he
has an eighth of coke 3.5 grams
you got about 120 bucks
no sorry he's 90. he got yeah about 90
bucks ready
so we're cleaning everything out i put
all the cleaning supplies in one box
like i said he has the whole sack and
i'm like yo that is the prettiest thing
i've ever seen is one big rock let's
let's get it and uh
he crushes it down it crushes the rock
down because like why have a big rock
and then he starts putting some out we
do one monster [ __ ] line
and we're honest for everybody at home
you have to imagine this if you're not
watching youtube here's the countertop
floor is down there here's the sink so
i'm looking at the sink to the left to
sink as a countertop just like most
people on earth he puts his shirt down
it's hot he puts his shirt down he's
wearing a [ __ ] uh
tank top he puts his shirt down
chopping up lines or whatever
puts the sack of coke on top of the
shirt
normal fine who cares but i go john
you're gonna grab your shirt forget the
sax on there it's gonna go into the sky
don't [ __ ] do that come on man final
destination [ __ ] see it see it first
okay like that's how i see everything
like yo you're gonna lose your drugs
devin sawwa
like final destination all right
and uh i go john don't do it because
thomas it's fine go john
just [ __ ] listen to me bro just put
it eight inches to the left that's what
she said like just put it to the left
man just don't put on the shirt you're
gonna move the shirt you're gonna knock
your sack over it was a tied up sack
it's not like he tied it back up
it's a coke sack and it's not a square
zip bag it's in the ones you make and
tie
so
it was frayed open
because the knot was on the side you
know you ripped the knot
being very descriptive because i need
you to see it
and we're doing that
monster line
cleaning everything cleaning everything
and i don't know why
i don't know how we both heard the sound
at the same time but i'm taking stuff
out and all i hear is
like
is that sand
the [ __ ] is that
and i go i look over and his whole sack
of coke is like on the edge on the shirt
because the shirt's bulky so it's got
room to tip
if it was on a flat surface it wouldn't
have tipped and it just went like that
and it was just pouring on his shirt and
all of it was pouring right out like off
the counter i looked down i'm like oh my
god thank god it's going into a box at
least we can
there's rocks in there still he just
broke up the big rock so there's rocks
and like a lot mostly powder but there's
rocks in it yo this podcast is
ridiculous this is a crazy part oh my
god sorry for everyone that's walking on
their [ __ ] children listening to the
[ __ ]
some professor what are you listening to
and there's coke rock right there's
on the ground what goes on and then
so back to the story
i go oh my god thank god's in a box and
i stop it i stop whatever's left like oh
maybe 0.3 left like in the remnants
i look down and go thank god it's in a
box i pick up the box and go john
there's no [ __ ] way you look at this
too i'm not lying
goes what what i could see it was like
what happened i go john
chi chin chong he goes what do you mean
look
every bit of coke fell into the box
which is totally great good news for us
what was in that box cleaning stuff
what do most people have [ __ ] ajax
ajax bottles spilled over everywhere
right at the bottom of the box what's
coke what's ajax
this is a [ __ ] movie and i looked at
john and go no one would ever [ __ ]
believe this you know that goes thomas
we can pull out those rocks ago john i
ain't doing it dude
i was like i can tell what's coke and
what's not
but you just lost like 3.3
there's nothing left
there's nothing left but you can see the
rocks what they were but what if that's
just ajax rock that got wet
and you snort ajax and it's no matter
what
you can't clean off a coke rock it's
made of coke rock
it will disappear when you wipe it
that's
called breaking it down
you can't get the ajax off you can't
it's fine snort it no and he was willing
he brought he busted out one of the
rocks and snorted the [ __ ] i went no he
goes oh no no it smells like hey jack's
going yeah john
that was probably [ __ ] it was covered
in ajax
movie scene movie scene and i go john
would i tell you what's going to happen
man it was thomas i don't even want to
talk about it right now
john
we got to talk about it right now you
should have listened to me dude because
i know
what are the [ __ ] and we were looking at
each other like
this is a good sign
we need to stop doing drugs we didn't
stop doing drugs but we're like maybe we
should stop doing drugs if
the whole [ __ ] day is gone because of
what just happened and i was so excited
when i saw it fall into the box because
i looked down this is all happening in
seconds i'm moving stuff and i hear it's
and we both go what the [ __ ]
because we thought like what is memphis
doing is he letting the air out of
something what is that
is the water leaking what the [ __ ] is
that nah bro that's rocks hitting
and the fact that we both heard the same
time was the best part
but yeah that's that's how he's lost the
sack of coke and i will always tell that
[ __ ]
so after every story time john would
text me right away like yo i remember
that day man because i never told what
we're talking about but you know any new
videos coming out man i'm like yeah man
i'm not gonna tell you what story it is
but this one's about me and you
and he loved that [ __ ] he's like yo it's
so fun listening to
the [ __ ] we did i know dude because when
i moved it was weird he'd be texting me
when i moved he was like he would text
me madden because he would one of the
percent madden question mark go yeah
let's do it come over here get high and
when i moved it was like an ongoing joke
like madden like yeah john
get online because i can't [ __ ] [ __ ]
you
you know i don't live there it was just
an ongoing joke yeah so he would text me
that [ __ ] periodically oh like
every couple weeks like madden like john
i'm in l.a bro but anyway
that's the that's the era that we were
in just playing video games and doing
stupid [ __ ] so that's 15 16. then we
actually smoked crack together and then
at
17
i just turned 17 in the senior year
yeah and senior year i turned 17 i was
on the cat bet bus the bus i talked
about story time where i popped [ __ ]
ecstasy and went to go teach kids soccer
that that that's the bus so this my last
period of the day was cat bet and cat
bets we
do you remember me at school in the
older high school kids would come teach
you dodgeball and teach you football do
you have that nah over here it's a it's
a class it's an elective you go to
different
each class goes to a different
elementary school and teaches them pe at
the last day
so you have all the older kids like yo
we're gonna play kickball and like
everybody's hiking cuz you know they're
older kids like yo what's high school
like billy yeah what's high school like
really like [ __ ] like that
and uh i love billy madison i would do
that so what's high school like man i i
would ask that question
and uh
when i got older my i'm gonna be in that
class one day and when i did i'm like
yeah catback give me cap that [ __ ] yeah
i'm gonna go [ __ ] have fun with these
kids it's gonna be sick anyway that's
the one i took ecstasy and i was
touching the grass and showed like an
idiot
bra was tripping balls in the heat about
the [ __ ] od from the heat exhaustion
and dumb [ __ ] because i took ecstasy
pills and i was trying to ditch but when
i tried to dance the [ __ ] security
officer was right [ __ ] there the only
other way was to my bus and what i'm
going to do it's like a checkpoint oh
you turn around no
you're you're done
that's where i was at checkpoint no i
went too far i'm going to cap it on
ecstasy
so i remember i was on that bus this is
where everything changed guys i was on
that bus
i was turning onto your mom and dad
street rosie where they live now i was
turning onto the street
and i got a call from john
a text he said call me i'm like what the
[ __ ] call me and she always just text me
i'm in school he knows that
it says call me
and he's like turning 27.
he's all called me and i called him
what's up man he goes
all right ma'am i'll tell you something
oh no what happened he goes
i just signed up for the army oh yeah
okay [ __ ]
so
what's up what do you want like why are
you calling me man you scared me he goes
thomas i just left the recruit's office
i just signed up for the army go john
we smoked bowls last night you're not
going to the [ __ ] army you're we're
going to smoke bowl what are you talking
about man because thomas
i don't have a job right now i don't
know what to do memphis is [ __ ] three
like what i need to do something and i
go john did you really sign up for the
[ __ ] army he goes thomas i have the
paperwork in my [ __ ] hand i just
signed up for four years i go no you
didn't you're a [ __ ] liar like i
didn't believe i hung up i was pissed
i'm like nope
going to class and i called him after my
so john what's going on he goes bro i
[ __ ] signed up john no you didn't
dude tell me what the [ __ ] i was so
[ __ ] mad like i didn't want to
believe the [ __ ]
i know you didn't no you [ __ ] didn't
dude because he showed me all the uh he
showed me the [ __ ]
full metal jacket he's the one to show
me platoon it's weird because
he's the one that showed me all the dope
movies and we used to watch full metal
chat he goes i've never gone to the army
i'll be pile just fat and everybody
beating my ass and he goes yeah john
don't ever go the [ __ ] army man
because he was kind of like a he wasn't
fat dude but he was the fastest person
for some [ __ ] reason always wear
flip-flops he was lightning fast as [ __ ]
and uh
i remember i come home
i see his ass we're neighbors and i go
yo
no no we're not neighbors anymore i'm at
my grandma and grandpa's
my grandma just passed away so i'm with
my grandpa
john and pepper have their i don't know
where they lived but anyway he was over
there and i'm like yo so what the [ __ ]
is going on you guys thomas i signed up
i look at pepper's like i'm like no
there's no way
can you stop it i'm like i was so
[ __ ] mad
you know what i mean i was so mad like
yo i'm about to get out of [ __ ] high
school fool i'm just about to graduate i
was just about to graduate from high
school like john
i'm gonna go get a job
we can hang out now like
it's time [ __ ] i don't have to ditch
anymore and you're leaving
i was 27. he's 10 years older than me i
was 16 turning 27.
i was 16 turning 26 uh turning 17. so he
was like 26 turning 27. he's 10 almost
11 years older i think
and i remember i was so [ __ ] mad at
him like bro
what are you doing to me don't do this
you know i mean i was mad like
stop it what are you doing man
that motherfucker's deployed he left
i remember when he left i was so [ __ ]
mad
i mean i was still like all right man
you're gonna all right all right you're
gonna do your thing okay we're good but
i was just mad like bro you chose that
why didn't you do that in high school so
by the time i got out we could hang out
it was like one of my best homies like
anthony and joe of course them
but i'm not always anthony joe when i'm
at home when i'm with like like me and
john are like yo it's christmas
sneak outside let's go smoke
you guys know that feeling that person
from you know you know that my sister
was so mean to me i never did that with
her
so you guys had that person at holidays
you're like oh yo you get the eye
that means let's go smoke a bowl outside
right now i got cologne i got [ __ ]
everything don't worry let's walk around
the building and we'll let you chill
that look
that's all those words and you guys know
that because you have those people and
that was my guy so
at you know christmas and this and like
we're always getting [ __ ] up and
sneaking off to do [ __ ] it was [ __ ]
fun oh we'll go get ice you know tom is
coming with me guys we're going to smoke
hella bulls there and
[ __ ] you
and it was just that was fun man you
know that was the [ __ ] so his [ __ ]
ass left
on good we're good we're good you got my
uncle go do your thing
come back how was it he comes back after
basic training and we [ __ ] got into
it like weirdly
he he was talking different
i don't know how to put it he was
talking like a meathead
like he was saying [ __ ] that i was like
[ __ ] you
what are you talking like i don't know
how to explain it but he was saying
things that made me like oh
and like his attitude his attitude
was like different
and i didn't he didn't drink him smoke
nothing
and i'm smoking i don't remember what it
was i don't remember what it was but
we're in my f we're in my [ __ ]
grandpa's living room on the flower
couches from the push trees house i took
those couches my grandpa left my grandpa
passed away i took his couches so i keep
him all those once in the first videos
where i was sitting on that [ __ ] rose
couch sitting on that couch tv's over
here my grandpa's over there on his
chair pepper's there memphis doing
something uncle john's right here
and i'm just about to uh i had just
graduated just got done with school and
then i moved out recently right after
but he came back i'm all hyped you know
his like after boot camp it's been like
three months he's been gone like oh yeah
he comes back all skinny and shame like
yo
and it's cool but i could tell like what
the [ __ ] is off about like your energy
is [ __ ]
and then i don't remember what we said
but i'm like you know what
you're a [ __ ] lame-ass fool [ __ ] you
like to his face i was serious like
you're [ __ ] lame he's sitting right
here he goes yeah i am [ __ ] lame huh
like he was going to hit me i go oh yeah
huh my uncle john could knock he he
doesn't look like an shaped person he
had the weirdest he's the lefty he had
the most the strongest you know that
punching machine probably with 900
somethings
every time
you don't look in shape you'll take my
head off that was a thing it's just
weirdly just very [ __ ] strong
and i'm looking at him like punch me in
the face [ __ ] i was like mad
like yeah hit me
[ __ ] you and i didn't say anything else
he looked at me like that i looked to
him didn't talk to him for four years
damn he moved away i mean he went and
deployed to the [ __ ] iraq he never
called me during his [ __ ] didn't write
nothing done like it was done like we
were like
[ __ ] you how long from when he got back
to when that happened was it
like when he came back to visit
he was there for like two weeks
and then he was deployed but what
happened like two weeks like two days in
damn days and i would go what's off
about you fool like what's wrong
i don't know what happened he said
something like you're [ __ ] lame [ __ ]
you i was pissed because i am [ __ ]
lame and i i could see his on his face
and like hit me full [ __ ] you
he didn't do she just looked at me i
looked at him we sat back
we did it all under our breath too
nobody else in the room
right next to us could hear us i was
like you know what [ __ ] you piece of
[ __ ] i was like mad
he said something super [ __ ] whack to
me and it pissed me off
and i don't ever get mad especially at
somebody i like
and he left bro he left they went to
hawaii
and why he deployed in iraq
i didn't talk to him at all not one
[ __ ] time nothing
nothing
and i remember like oh [ __ ] he's done
with his tour um it was uh just turned
17 i was turning i was 21 turning 22.
just started dating rosie just started
dating rosie
and i was telling her like well michael
john like he's like my
older brother but
we're on weird [ __ ] right now he's
he's being a weird [ __ ] like i
was telling her what happened before he
left
and he came back regular john
he came back normal john and i was so
[ __ ] happy
he came in
i went and picked him up
and i'm the second i saw him i go oh
you're normal john oh [ __ ] yeah and he
goes i'm out of the army man
let's get [ __ ] up oh so you won't
smoke weed now he goes yeah i don't want
to [ __ ] do anything anymore he got uh
honorably discharged he was jumping out
of the helicopter and the last guy and
nobody can hear because it's a
helicopter in the sky you jumping out of
the helicopter the big no yeah the big
helicopter with like the back thing that
goes with all the soldiers in it yeah
and nobody could hear but he was the
last guy to jump out
oh it was on the ground
like they had parked so everybody's like
you know jumping out get out let's go do
our thing
and when he was leaving his trap stage
straps when he jumped out it's his it
stuck to his arm and twisted his his
hand behind his head this way she's so
it like ripped everything in his
shoulder and he was there for like 35
minutes and they were like yo where is
strange yeah where the [ __ ] he at and
he's sitting there screaming his head
off for somebody and nobody can hear him
because there's hell helicopters they're
doing like a
training exercise so nobody could hear
him so he literally couldn't use his arm
he was in like a like a sling for months
but they gave him like [ __ ] benefits
for us for his life and [ __ ] cause he
was hanging there for like 45 minutes
damn
he passed out what happened he passed
out from
shock
because he was just sitting there all
body weight hanging on his arm i can't
even lift my arm that way but his his
wrist he was like my wrist was on here i
could feel my ear and i'm hanging by
like off the helicopter just sitting
there and nobody can hear because all
the blades
uh wild
so that's why he came home like he did
he didn't re-up on his contract he's
like i'm done man
they pay me every [ __ ] month
man and i got my gi bill i'm like oh
john oh you [ __ ] seriously yep
i get paid forever it's like all right
now i see why you went cool and he's
like i didn't mean to hurt myself anyway
dance joint went out
sorry guys i'll speed this up damn it's
a long that's a long one
uh weird it's so weird talking about
this and uh i picked him up i'm like so
do you want to smoke weed and when he
left remember
i was selling we would show here and
there like getting zips
excuse me
by 1920 i was still in 10 packs 20 packs
i was i had a weed
and when it was us he was getting 80
sacks and he's wearing a pizza place and
buy zips and i can buy ounces
so a pound of weed we both never saw
so when he came back oh
so since you left john i've been selling
a lot of weed he goes oh cool and i go
no i've been it's different now and i'm
like yo this is like the 30 pack here
you go what the [ __ ] is going on and i
remember his face like thomas
sick he's like yeah
he was all about i go that's the only
change man and i was like also i'm
dating this girl she's really cool blah
blah blah and then i picked him up he's
like all right let's smoke
and the first night she ever met him is
the day he got back and he came to my
house that first night rosie everybody
pushed tree's house i heard rosie
introduced to him i'm like all right
hit the bong
and he hadn't smoked in four [ __ ]
years
he hadn't drank really he stopped
drinking like two years after before the
army ended because he was getting too
[ __ ] up he said no iraq he told me
what happened he was getting drinking
bottles and [ __ ] just chugging him
because he's like i'm juice guarding oil
fields with guns at kids like bro i
can't do that he was all pissed
um
his job out there too was to drive
high personnel high ranking
he's driving through the towns in iraq
and his job was you cannot stop if
someone gets in your way you run him
over like you don't stop like it's in
the city because it's in a city bro
regular people living their lives and i
go in 130.
all right he's like but if we stop he'll
probably get killed so that
the way he was explaining is it was very
stressful because he's he's i always
said i can't fall asleep in a car my dad
my mom my uncle john only people i could
fall asleep in a car when they drive the
only people that chose my life
fully
i'll tell you a little bit more about
john's striving in a minute because i
made fun of him forever here we go
he gets back he hits the bong
the hand kill oh
he does that number and he's drinking
with me and he has not drank or smoked
what happens when you drink mixed drink
and weed oh you're in for it he got so
shit-faced in 30 minutes flat party
spoon [ __ ] face not throwing up just
[ __ ] up and it's
my uh as my uncle from a kid i could
[ __ ] with him he's like i know him so
well i could [ __ ] with him and he's not
gonna get mad at me and [ __ ]
so when he passed out an hour in i mean
done done he only hit the bong one
[ __ ] time
and then i rolled i pulled a blunt or a
joint and then he started smoking that
with us and then he was out
i
duct taped his feet together like his
ankle by the ankle i duct taped the [ __ ]
out of it so if he had to get up in the
middle of the night he would just fall
while he was going back and you're lucky
he didn't wake up on some ptsd [ __ ] and
[ __ ]
it's funny
i'm not done
i'm not done
my magic marker all right he just got
back all right he just got back you
passed out all right [ __ ] you
i drew glasses on him but you like
[ __ ]
all this stuff on his face i drew one
time i drew a dick
on his cheek
but i i drew anklets on his ankles too
because he always wear flip-flops no
matter where he was at shorts and
flip-flops a coke cold shirt or a
[ __ ] sun-kissed shirt [ __ ] ac dc
shirt the same
[ __ ] and he didn't have a car because he
just got back because his car was
shipping still and he was staying with
his sister till they got a house
and she lived like two miles away and he
gets up at five in the morning no matter
what so he was gone by the time i woke
up because i was passing out like three
or four drunken [ __ ] he's getting up
like
my [ __ ] ankles
and uh
i drew all over him i woke up around
nine to check on him my front door is
unlocked and there's just duct tape in
balls everywhere
and he's gone and then i attached my
pepper and she goes he'd even know you
drew all over me walked all the way
through town
at [ __ ] six in the morning with his
dick on his face and anklets
i drew eggplants on his ankles look at
this
day one
ready for day two
there's like seven days straight we did
this he came over trying to like chill
hang out like yeah john we got we got
boxes before was like let's get a sack
oh [ __ ] okay let's conserve this bowl
and now it's like no no
i smoked like it was different you know
he just supplied me with me and now it's
like no
i got it don't worry
so we're getting [ __ ] up
i'm just duct taping him
shut
everything he passed out again like a
couple he lasted like an hour an extra
hour today an extra hour today
and uh
i duct tape his wrist and his feet
together i drew all over him again i
taped his his fisherman hat to his head
like i wrap around it was funny
and um
i did that for about five days straight
i drew all over them i i don't know
where they are rosie but i have pictures
of it i pictured him like that i drew
eye his eye eyes open on his eyelids
it was really funny man
so i did that to him and about day seven
he got his tolerance back yeah
and then that was it man that was that
was it we just he was back and my uncle
john was back all right did you ever
address the fallen author you didn't
have to even talk about it
no i didn't think about it we never even
talked about it i'm only one joint
deemed talking about this
hey what's up guys welcome to the
mid-roll ad read like i said before
thank you so much for supporting the
brands that support us if you watched a
few episodes ago guys you would have saw
us introduce on it this is one of our
new sponsors and if you've been watching
podcast for a long time you already know
this is one of the biggest podcast
sponsorships so basically if you're
working out you're doing the supplements
you're doing all that stuff they have
every single thing you could possibly
imagine on their website it's onit.com
onnit.com forward slash yola or the code
yolo that's 10 off of anything on their
website except for the weights but
that's the gear the clothes the
supplements the vitamins everything else
besides the weights that's 10 off so
like i said if you listen to podcasts
you've seen this on the joe rogan show
for years he's part owner of this so
that's why you see the gear having a lot
of dmt influence and the monkeys and the
apes it's just it's actually pretty
[ __ ] cool they have something called
alpha brain that's something i'm
actually using as you can see it's not
on the table because i took it home and
i'm gonna try it out for a week i'm
gonna see how it really affects me if it
really helps this is actually just
[ __ ] empty box because that is in my
house right now all of it is top quality
ingredients this is not
just the stuff you buy horny goat pill
you know what i mean at 7 11 with all
the energy [ __ ] it's not like that guys
they have vegan options they have
non-vegan options they have something
for every single person out there and
yes guys i'm still keeping up on i've
been hitting the weights i've been doing
everything i've been trying this is the
whole life change i'm trying to do guys
i'm trying to be a healthy [ __ ]
and this is the start
before you back to the episode guys i
want to say a special shout out to one
of our sponsors this is keeps if you
already heard of this brand you might be
one of the 50 million men that are
suffering from hair loss this is not
just for people that are already losing
their hair that want to gain it back
this is for people like me that don't
want it to happen this is hair loss
prevention this is hair thickening gels
there's hair it's for everyone i'm sure
some of you out there right now are
going [ __ ] man i kind of want to use
that it's not something anybody wants to
go through no dude at 15 is like yo i
can't wait till i'm in my 30s starting
to lose my hair nobody [ __ ] wants
that at one point of our lives every
single dude out here every single dude
is gonna have to go through some form of
this unless you're christopher lloyd
from back to the future you don't have
to [ __ ] worry about that but for me
and you eventually it's gonna happen so
for keeps guys this is 100 discreet it's
confidential it comes to your house
there is no doctor visit you don't have
to go to the doctor and talk to a dude
about what he's going through too so
guys if you have any interest in this at
all go to www.keeps.com
k-e-e-p-s dot com forward slash yola
that that code right there the yolo code
from the podcast you get one month the
first month you get for free all right
you get the whole month for free and
then after that it starts at 10 bucks a
month no matter what it's a it's 10
bucks a month man it's cheaper than any
other competitor on the planet and it's
got more five star reviews than any
other hair growth or hair loss company
in the world there are only two hair
loss drugs in the world that are
approved by the fda and keeps has both
and guys i've looked through the dms
we've had multiple people erase it i
bought this for my dad i bought this for
my husband bought this for my brother
guys shout out to you like i said i say
it all the time thanks for supporting
the brands that support us all the links
will always be on the episode no matter
where you're listening to there will be
a link again guys
www.keeps.com it's your first month for
free thank you guys so much for watching
back to the episode
we're hour and a half i'm trying to try
to keep this episode tight guys all
right here we go
so let's go
i'm 22.
i'm 22.
john's back [ __ ] yeah
so i don't know how many things we did i
couldn't tell you all the stuff we did
we just got [ __ ] up all the time we
played madden all the time the push
trees house screen door with the screws
we used a hammer
because the screw gun wasn't working so
we hammered in the screws
like geniuses
uh any single [ __ ] time anything
happened or i needed anything was there
in five [ __ ] seconds
everywhere no matter what the [ __ ] i did
so
here we go
rosie's in the picture now
john and rosie are cool [ __ ] together
like they're they love each other it's
super cool john
hell likes rose i'm like [ __ ] yes
awesome so everything's cool man
everything's going good
uh we're getting [ __ ] up all the time
he's coming over i got the new house
he's all hyped about he got the money
he's all hyped about like
he's like all you know like all positive
and [ __ ] toward what whatever the [ __ ]
we were doing and um he was going to
college while i was going to college too
which was weird seeing him all go at
school it was so odd
and uh
you're your stepdad there too right yeah
yeah he didn't he never i don't know if
he ever crossed him i never i never
asked him but uh
yeah so years are going on right
so from 22 to 26
what the [ __ ]
that's it
wow
that's so lame i didn't realize how
short of a time that we chilled until he
was gone but
22 to 26 to live in merced he was over
all the time
hanging out 26 i moved to l.a well
that's like four years is when you think
about four years as the length of high
school it seems like a [ __ ] lifetime
yeah
but um
at 26 i moved to la
and i remember he helped me pack my
stuff
and he was waving as i drove off type
[ __ ]
and
uh
drove down
moved he
texted me like every other day likes to
see what's going on
and the first couple years we lived here
i was going back to merced every other
week
so i was getting [ __ ] up with john
every other week
oh real quick because this makes sense
later
he bought a car when his son was a
couple months old
old car right next to his childhood home
he stared at the car his whole life and
the guy was like i'm selling the car all
right i'll buy it old but 6 1962 buick
electra super sick car
and he goes i'm gonna fix it up by the
time memphis is
seven i go john
memphis will be 18 [ __ ] and
you're not gonna fix that damn car come
on you're never going to do it you're
not a car i was just talking [ __ ] he
goes i'll bet you'll go john i'll bet
you 100 [ __ ] dollars i'll give you
until he's 18. not until he's 7.
my cousin turns 18 in 17 days marty
17 days my cousin memphis will be 18
august 20th
and uh
today's august 3rd obviously
so in 17 days i would have won 100
all right let me just say that damn so
he had the car in his garage so i'd be
going back to merced yo what's up here's
all the new because i started doing
reviews and stuff like yawn all the
stuff you've ever seen i give to my
uncle john and my sister and my friends
at merced so my uncle always had the
cool new [ __ ]
he didn't dab he didn't like dabbing
uh you'll never see me smoking that it
looks like math uncle john what did you
say about cocaine full
and he took a dab but the last time i
chilled with him he took a dab which is
so odd to say
um
and uh i'd go back we'd smoke weed with
him i'd give him you know give him
[ __ ] weed i got this away from this
company here smoke is i got this
syrup something something edibles never
hit him so i'd always try to get him
[ __ ] up i tried this edible nope
didn't work so forever forever um so i
periodically be going back every time
i'd go back
if i could we'd stop by hang out but i
was always in a rush so we never like
hung out for a full night anymore you
know what i mean it was or christmas
time and [ __ ] like that yes holidays
we'd be getting [ __ ] up
we'd be smoking as much weed as possible
in the garage while everybody's in the
house or
you know the old thing
so
we did that for years and years and
years and then
you know i'm like a couple years past
since i lived here
i still see him he always texts me
what's going on but when i started
filming a lot he would stop texting me
so much he's like oh i know you're busy
might be full
text me what the [ __ ] wrong with you
so
i'll let you hit me up like no [ __ ]
hit me up so you'd hit me up every
couple days still and he [ __ ] like i
said he loved story time so [ __ ] much
because he's like dude i remember that
[ __ ] day like
right i'm so glad i'm so glad you
remember because i have a witness
[ __ ] like that [ __ ] was real and
uh
and he loved he loves story time right
and um
he called me after like every [ __ ]
video or he'd text me like yo that
editing was crazy like when i started
working with you like what the [ __ ] yeah
i'm working with a new guy like this is
crazy like it's [ __ ] like a movie the
five thousand milligram challenge i
remember he's like what the [ __ ] was
that basketball [ __ ] i know right look
crazy anyway he was all over this [ __ ]
even though he didn't do social media i
he's so funny he says that he's the
funniest person i ever met so i made him
make twitter
because i'm like john please just make a
tweet he goes what is ziggler
you know what he just said
say that on twitter
but make up a fake character and then
it'll be funny
and he did and he started
using twitter for like a year
when he passed away i went through all
this all of it like yo
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
oh my god dude the some of the
one-liners this [ __ ] has are so
good dude
anyway um i started making use twitter
and [ __ ] anyway he would always hit me
up all this stuff all this stuff all
this stuff
let's fast forward
pandemic hits
uh well right before the pandemic is his
birth is october 19th so 2019
his birthday to october
first time i ever recorded him or took a
picture of him
because he hates being on camera so i
never bust my phone out and we're
chilling and [ __ ]
um
his birthday i take him to dtpg he's
never seen a weed plant growing like
hell i'm gonna it's your birthday i'm
gonna take you to this place he goes all
right
his face when he walked like what the
[ __ ] is this you know commercial groves
i was like wait what
and we're all smoking a joint and i'm
like john do me a [ __ ] favor just
take this [ __ ] picture full
it's like
i just take the [ __ ] picture it's
your birthday you've never been in a
grove [ __ ] you
and i have him like passing the joint
there's a picture of him i think i post
showed you he's like passing the joint
to the camera and it's like
and there's all these weed plants and uh
it's the only picture i have taken of
him really yeah right i don't have any
pictures and uh
we're at the crow
hanging out it's his birthday he [ __ ]
he was all psyched about like you know
i've never seen that much weed i'm like
i know right
because you know me and him go back to
watching half-baked like yo pounds
please ah stealing the pounds we always
reference that like they're good jenkins
and
like john no there's more pounds than
that in this one room
it's thomas what the [ __ ]
because he goes back to damn i remember
blackbeard's delight that's what he
called my weed because he thought it was
nasty it was like darker when i first
started getting front and weave from
this guy chris it was like not good weed
oh that blackbeard's delight because we
used to watch anchorman's a lot he's
like um blackbeard's delight we're
smelling the colognes we would just
everything was a movie reference so he
used to call my wee black beards delight
and he goes this thing blackbeard i go
no it's not [ __ ] you there's fire and
then we're in the room he's like thomas
ten years what a difference you know
we're like i know right
remember we should me and him we're
drinking sparks we're drinking sparks
there's energy drinking alcohol we're
smoking out of his bong in his backyard
in 7-eleven when you sleep next 7-11
together
and he goes one day man i want someone
just to pay me to try weed and drink
beer all [ __ ] day and i go john
one day it's gonna happen a star was
born that's what he said i told him like
one day wow we'll get it done
hello john
one day we will get it done man
someone's gonna be like yo try this weed
tell me how you like it maybe let's just
record it or something you know
that's probably a real job i told him
like that's probably a real job
somewhere someone's doing this wouldn't
that be [ __ ] crazy i was like 14 15
when he said that fast forward he's
telling me remember when we talk like
john
i know isn't it crazy and oh yeah you
know how i did it by talking about the
stuff we used to do
which is so crazy that's why he loved
the show like watching episodes so much
like
yo that's awesome like i know man isn't
it crazy like dude you tell because he
was so hyped that you tell it so [ __ ]
well like i'm there i'm like you were
there
[ __ ] you were there but he was so
hyped
so fast forward oh his birthday i had a
video of him drink i'd never taken a
video of him chugging a [ __ ]
medicated drink
only video i only video i have of him
and uh
so the college episode of story time
comes out that's last year college
episode comes out and i'm talking about
the mexican girls hitting on me did you
just really get here that [ __ ] gang
banger ass [ __ ]
and uh
10 seconds after the video goes this
full text me did you just barely get
here
and i'm like oh you [ __ ] you
were watching the [ __ ] out of that you
were in the premiere [ __ ]
and um
and that was the last text i got before
he got sick like he got sick so randomly
and i haven't talked about it yet so
here we go
uh
so
he text me
june 3rd i was editing a video
on my computer editing a video
i know exactly what i was doing
and he goes
hey fool i had to go to the [ __ ]
hospital like i think i have pneumonia
again because he had pneumonias like 20
times in his life randomly he had a
shitty ass childhood
and uh
he's like i [ __ ]
he should smoke a lot of sex he stopped
smoking cigs like
10 years ago he's like oh
they're gonna kill me and then like
three years ago i saw him smoking a
swisher plane i go what the [ __ ] are you
doing he's like
i know but it's only been a week ago
stop because all right i'll stop
but he just smoked cigs and he used to
say oh there's a fire in my chest that's
what he used to say all the time he
would smoke it
ah there's a fire in my chest he would
say it all the time he's like damn my
chest he anything that's like bad he
would make a joke out of he goes fire in
my chest he used to say all the time
but his lungs hurt because he always had
pneumonia as a kid he would smoke 10
packs of cigarettes and [ __ ] he would
smoke two packs of cigs every time we
were drinking we would always talk [ __ ]
like yo you gotta please please stop
smoking so many [ __ ] cigarettes he
would go through three packs of camel
non-filters that's why i used to smoke
because of him camel non-filters i smoke
packs and packs and packs
and he stopped smoking he's like [ __ ]
all right i'll stop [ __ ] i'm like 32
i'll stop
and he stopped
and
he texts me that he goes hey man i had
to go to the hospital i can i don't know
if your aunt told you he's like i'm fine
don't trip he's like but damn dude my
[ __ ] chest hurt i smoked some weed
[ __ ] fire in my chest and go damn
full what did you smoke i made a joke
like what the [ __ ] you smoking
hurt your lungs
and he goes
oh just some weird i got from zone zone
like the guy hooked him up with like oh
then it's fire because i know who he
gets it from it's fire it's fine
and he's like i think i got pneumonia
again or some [ __ ] bronchi all right
cool
let me know what
happens texts me june 3rd
how weird june 3rd i remember the day
of editing
and then he said
a couple days later like yo i haven't
been smoking i've been eating hella
edibles we'll see if the [ __ ] works i
go what'd you get he starts naming all
the companies off i'm like
i think you're gonna feel it man
and then he hits me up like two days
later he goes i [ __ ] fell asleep i
passed out they finally hit me i wish
they wouldn't hit me so hard like damn
finally
took 20 years
for you to finally [ __ ] feel some
edibles and um
he hits me up again he goes i don't know
i'm about to go to doctors like my
[ __ ] chest hurts dude it's [ __ ]
[ __ ] he's like i stopped smoking for
a week i'm feeling better but i smoked
some bulls this morning and it just hurt
i go okay
let me know what's going on right
[ __ ] happened so fast
things happened so quick
and i didn't see him
except one time when i came to town
i stopped at his house i lied what are
you doing like i'm just walking around
with your hand like all right
and i pulled up on because i knew
exactly where he was at walking with her
and i just
just to [ __ ] with him like i knew you
were [ __ ] merced i know i was just
[ __ ] around what's up and uh they had
just moved to this news house last year
so we hadn't smoked bowls together yet
because covid and all that [ __ ] so we
hadn't smoked wool since the time his
birthday when he went to dtpg 2019
so fast forward with seven no like nine
months
you know i see him at christmas
that's it i see him at christmas what we
whatever
and then
i haven't smoked with him since and then
pandam's going all the [ __ ]
and he goes oh so yeah i guess i don't
know what's going on let's go doctor
blah blah blah
like all right let me know what's going
on dude and it's covid and he hates
smartphones i don't wanna the phone's
for calling fool i'm not gonna look at
no [ __ ] pictures but john stop being
stupid [ __ ] i sent you a video
look at it so that was his thing so he
didn't have a smartphone he's like i
don't care about pictures [ __ ] you i
don't care about facetime so he'd have
smartphone so he'd i just text him all
the time and it makes sense in a minute
why i brought it up
and um
he hits me i was like dude i to the
[ __ ] hospital
what the [ __ ] my [ __ ] chest hurts
like dude what
so he goes to the doctor and he's
texting me this he's texting me this my
aunt's like yo john's sick like we have
to go to the [ __ ] doctor i'm like
[ __ ] and she goes he never washes his
mask that [ __ ] he wears the same
mask all every day i guarantee you got
some bacteria from [ __ ] wearing the
mask like john you dirty [ __ ]
because i know him he wears the same hat
every day like her mask is dirty i know
it is [ __ ]
so
he hits me up he's like dude so i have
pneumonia or some [ __ ] and there's fluid
in my lungs like [ __ ]
it's like i'm going to be at the
hospital and pepper can't even come in
because i'm [ __ ] covered it's some
[ __ ]
so he goes to the hospital like
like june 15th or some [ __ ] right
and it's like
every texas is worse i saw what they say
he says so they're gonna drain the fluid
they're gonna put a tube right here and
drain the fluid out i'm like john for
real bro
he goes yeah i don't know what the [ __ ]
to do like i have fluid in my lungs it's
not covered they test me every [ __ ]
two hours
and he's a veteran so he's at the vet
veterans va [ __ ] so they're taking care
of him
remember guys
i'm doing all the [ __ ] like the videos
i'm doing all the stuff i mean you're
talking about the podcast that we're
still trying to get [ __ ] done
and i'm like just texting him like every
other hour just like yo how are you
feeling
you know to keep because he don't text
people you [ __ ] my aunt my mom i said
you don't text fools he doesn't hang out
with nobody so i'm texting him like yo
how you feeling well you know
there's a senile old man in my he's my
room my roommate
and he is watching fast and furious in
spanish
loud
and i go sick which one he goes six oh
damn that sucks because i know
and then i'm texting him texting him
texting him
and then he texts me in the middle of
the night the first night he goes i just
watched hobbs and something the new
he's like i just watched hobbs and
whatever the new movie the new fast
furious it's all six times in a row you
jealous and i'll go bro no
no he's like
six [ __ ] he's senile he doesn't
remember if he just watched the movie
thomas and he just replayed it again
dude
so yep
so i know what the rock sounds like in
spanish and i go damn y'all you're
[ __ ] idiot he's just making jokes
right he's just [ __ ] with me i'm like
damn
no i'm not jealous bro i'm not gonna go
watch hobbs and shaw that's what it was
having shaw and uh
damn i just chug that beer [ __ ]
how long has it been almost two hours
i'm sorry i'm getting close we'll get
close
and uh
so he tells me all that stuff blah blah
blah they don't know what's wrong so now
they're draining this now they're
draining that and then they're like so
you have like an ammonia infection and
there's fluid that you know your heart
has a sack he's like there's fluid
around your heart
in the sack he's like what the [ __ ]
my child are you [ __ ] kidding me
it's my own like chill like are you sick
for real
he goes thomas i don't know what the
[ __ ] going on some [ __ ] these
fools are leaving me in here your aunt
can't come in here i haven't seen your
aunt that's some bull you know i'm
texting him ever he's texting me
everything paragraphs paragraphs
paragraphs
and um
i'm texting him just trying to like keep
him and keep him like hyped or like yo
you're good don't worry a couple more
days full couple more days
coldwater and he sends me a picture and
i'm like oh my [ __ ] god bro there's
like a hole in his chest in the tube
and he's just looking at me with his
mask on he just like took a picture of
it of himself my god what does it look
like and he just send me a picture
bro you look sick and i hadn't seen him
yet like you look [ __ ] sick
if i'd say anything like you look
[ __ ] sick dude
and uh like okay cool
let me know what's going on i'm trying
to like not to get all worried in texts
i'm trying to keep him like
you're good [ __ ] yeah you're good and
then he's texting me all this stuff week
goes by
day 17 day 18 with a tube in his chest
they said oh it should take a few hours
it's day 18 because now there's an
infection and now there's this and now
they [ __ ] up so they have to redo it
and like all this [ __ ]
and he still hasn't seen my pepper once
he hasn't seen anybody
so everybody out there i don't want to
wear a mask [ __ ] some people in the
hospital can't not see people because
your bitch-ass won't wear a mask not
just because you won't get sick i didn't
get to see michael john once right he's
in the hospital for a month and a half i
didn't get to go in there one [ __ ]
time i drove from la to sac twice
didn't get to see him
so [ __ ] you wear your mask
and uh
the covered restrictions i'm not saying
anything about being sick i'm saying the
restrictions nobody wears a mask they're
like mandatory you can't come in
and this is at the peak of it this is
last july right june
and then it's going by it's going by
and then he texts me goes just had my
first heart attack weird
and i go
shut the [ __ ] up full and i'm texting
like john don't say [ __ ] like he's like
thomas just had a heart attack it was
very odd
i didn't know what was happening and i
felt really started explaining it to me
i'm like did you really have he's like
probably had a heart attack
sitting here in my bed four or five
minutes this [ __ ] didn't come help me
he's like he's always hitting the button
nobody came so fresno va [ __ ] you
and um
he's telling me all this [ __ ] i'm like
john are you [ __ ] kidding me dude
what
what's going on and now i'm like
[ __ ] i'm like really like i don't know i
was in my kitchen when he told him like
what the [ __ ]
just text me as much as you possibly can
let me know what's going on because i
can't call him he can't talk he's a
breathing thing on and he can't face
time
for me to see him and talk because he
doesn't [ __ ] with smartphones he doesn't
like it
so i'm just sending him sending him [ __ ]
like random [ __ ] like i'm like oh that's
what i'm editing today i just ate five
thousand milligrams and [ __ ] like that
or you know i mean like i'm just telling
him with the new [ __ ] he's like what
[ __ ] like you know just keeping him up
to date he's not watching youtube he's
not at home he doesn't know what the
[ __ ] i'm doing so i'm trying to keep him
all [ __ ] hyped and spirits and then
uh
oh yeah one second
so here we go [ __ ] here we go so
july 3rd
i went to bed really late
went to bed really late and i was like
five or six when i went to bed i
remember and i'm waking up to a call at
like nine and it's john i'm like
immediately
okay his picture when he calls is
richard pryor
and there's a quote that says i know i'm
not addicted to cocaine i just love the
way it smells and that's his picture
when he calls is richard pryor big black
screen richard pryor and that quote and
i'm like oh john
yeah because i know like oh sick because
i have a hell of a friend's name john
like
nobody is just john it's john this john
that and john's the only one that just
says because that's the origin like that
i know him you know
and uh
i see the thing i'm like i see it
automatically and i'm waiting on the
hour like how you doing what are you
doing what are you doing and he calls me
i'm like you're calling me what the [ __ ]
so he calls me and i'm in bed my eyes
are closed and i'm awake i'm awake but
my eyes aren't opening yet you know i'm
trying and i'm just talking to him like
you're sleeping no i'm i'm i'm awake i'm
what's up man i'm just trying to like
sound normal so he's like oh i'll talk
to you later i might not [ __ ] that [ __ ]
wait what are you doing he goes
all right i'm gonna talk to you i need
to tell you some [ __ ] i'm like oh my
[ __ ] god because i have stage four
cancer they just said i have stage four
lung cancer and i remember i'm like
trying not to like break down like
don't worry about it all right there's
rso there's green something treatments
there's this there's that there's chemo
there's this i have friends that make
all the best cbd in the [ __ ] planet
and and i'm not saying that yet i'm
telling he's saying he's like i've
staged four [ __ ] cancer i'm like oh
my god
and i'm trying not to get sad i'm trying
to like stay calm
and he goes yeah i don't know how they
missed it they just walked in said it
and walked the [ __ ] out
i'm like
so this is real you see i have stage
four lung cancer
they found like five tumors in my lungs
all this [ __ ] blah blah
i remember what he said i'm just not
gonna say everything but
he's telling me all this crazy [ __ ] i'm
like then i start going don't worry cbd
i have the [ __ ] my friend carter is
the world's best [ __ ] cbd guy in the
planet for real medicinals i'm like
don't worry i'll drive to sac that's why
i drove a sack i drove the sack to get
the medicine all this [ __ ] and
remember that's july third
and he's like
man how long have i known you and i go
john
don't talk like i'm late
i mentioned i was 10 bro i was like i
mentioned i was 10 years old
and he's like you're about to you're
about to turn 30 level am like yep he
goes 20 years everybody said 20 years
i'm like
oh he is he's sick
[ __ ] [ __ ] like i knew he was super sick
like 20 years huh
oh
yeah 20 years man it's been 20 [ __ ]
years remember
you you look like sabretooth from x-men
he goes oh yeah
he's like oh that's right in the [ __ ]
gold's gym park or gb3 park i'm like
john that's the day i met you man and
i'm like
don't worry we're gonna be okay
you're gonna be fine
everything's good don't worry blah blah
blah you know i'm just trying to like
keep him like he's like i can hear the
tube like
and he's like oh yeah i know
you know when you say you know i won't
i'll fight to the end and that's his
things like i'm not a quitter he always
said that [ __ ] you know i'm not a
quitter he also is stan smith without
having a government job
he has all the guns in the world and all
the training in the world remember i
said he's in the army
he came back with a love for guns he has
so many [ __ ] guns in his house when
the pandemic happened he's like i'll
drive you some [ __ ] machine gun right
now like don't worry bro like when some
[ __ ] happen i remember was like
i think this guy gotta get killed i
think we have to kill this guy i'm not
gonna say everything but i was i was
contemplating killing somebody so one
time like
if i'm serious i'll talk to john because
i know he'll go with me and do it with
me like i i some weird should happen i
will never talk about story time but i
was leaving at that i'm like you know
what i'm not gonna open that box because
the second i tell him what's going on
he's gonna come over here with five guns
and it's gonna be that's it
but i remember like
you'll do anything for me for i [ __ ]
like you know what i mean like that
person you will do whatever the [ __ ] i
ask you for because you're so down
anyway he has all the guns in the
[ __ ] planet the reason i brought that
up because i'm like don't even stressful
you'll [ __ ] be all skinny cancer fool
trying to get all buffed with guns like
you'll [ __ ] get in shape like i'm
just trying to like hype him you know
what i mean like don't worry man you're
gonna get all skinny at least you won't
be fat no more because he's like i'm
getting fat that's one of the things you
always talk about i'm [ __ ] fat now
[ __ ] i left the army
he's got fat as [ __ ] he got [ __ ]
fatty [ __ ] it was really funny
he looked like david cross when he was
gone
like he was just like some dude with a
big gray beard bald head white dude he's
like david cross anyway um
he tells me all that stuff i'm like
don't worry he gets out of the phone and
by the time i got the phone i could look
at rosie and rosie really knows what's
going on i don't know how she knew but
she knew exactly what the fight he was
saying
and i was just like trying to hold it
together like okay [ __ ] and everyone was
in my bed and i looked up my ceiling i'm
like
july 3rd
[ __ ]
and i remember thinking like you know
when you're a kid and you think oh yeah
my friends and everybody will be around
forever
and you're like i wonder if they did
pass away when would it be but you're
like no don't say a date don't ever
think about that don't say that put that
out there you know when you're a kid
like when what year will it be when i go
type [ __ ]
and i remember like july third [ __ ] this
is not and it's the first time i ever
like put a date on some [ __ ] like that
like
july 3rd sucks
and uh june 3rd he told me man my chest
feels shitty i'm trying to smoke some
bowls did you just barely get here july
3rd
i mean june 3rd july 30 is like i have
stage four [ __ ] lung cancer i'm like
this is some
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
so
everything's going on i talked to my
aunt she's all [ __ ] sad and [ __ ]
obviously i'm trying to like don't worry
i got this treatment this treatment this
stream and blah blah it's all the stuff
for wheat weed stuff right i'm not
saying anything secret i'm keeping
something from you it's just rick
simpson oil cbd treatments uh green
juice raw diets [ __ ] like that stomach
cleanse this cleanse poor clot all that
stuff
i'm like telling my aunt don't worry i'm
going to get in the car i'm going to
[ __ ] sack i'm going to get you
everything so we we drove to sac
i was about to buy the mercedes and i
went i'm not buying the mercedes because
he's going to be sick
i need to have a car i can just drive
back and forth back forth back and forth
back forth go hang out with him and [ __ ]
i don't want to put the miles in the car
i'm like well [ __ ] the car [ __ ] the car
and i said [ __ ] the car and that was in
july
and then all this shit's going on he
texts me i'm texting him on the hour
basically like what's going on
like why aren't they there because then
it started to get into where the va was
just like not taking care of him
like they weren't taking care of him at
all
don't know what the [ __ ] the problem was
he was like dude it's been like six
hours i've been hitting this button they
haven't came yet dude i had a [ __ ]
heart attack you see the machinery and
he's sitting there staring at the
machine like well i went over 150
something and that's why i started
having a heart so he's like panicking
himself like it's at 160 and he started
like getting we like scared and he was
texting me like it's at this it's at
this it's at this i'm like john
stop looking at the [ __ ] machine dude
it's going to drive you crazy you can't
do that to yourself
and um
he's like i know
and
he's like hey i had another heart attack
this morning i'm like john you gotta
stop telling me this [ __ ] so casual bro
it's [ __ ] me up you please stop
tell me the [ __ ] but don't be like oh
yeah by the way i had a heart attack
that's why i was hitting the button like
john what the [ __ ]
and i'm just imagining like you're by
yourself [ __ ] man it's kovid you're with
some guy that doesn't speak the language
you speak you can't talk to him and he's
senile
like you're by yourself you can't talk
to my aunt you can't really talk on the
phone because the breathing machine
so he's just by himself
you see him saying like he's sitting by
himself
so all that covered restrictions [ __ ]
you guys understand why it sucks
this isn't nobody got to see his ass
so everything's going on guys
um the tube finally comes out like july
10th
no no no like july 20th 22nd the tube
comes out and everybody's texting me
like they said one more day all right
they said two more days they said and
he's texting me every piece of
information that's happening so i'm like
i'm doing [ __ ] videos
texting this fool like i'm trying to
not miss any text from him you know what
i'm saying i can't i can't because every
five seconds in the hospital when you
think you're [ __ ] dying is an hour so
i'm trying to be like no every time you
text i'm down bam bam bam trying to you
see what i'm saying i'm trying to keep
his hopes up and [ __ ] remember guys uh
this is like one of my best [ __ ]
friends but he just happens to be my
uncle
and he's going through all this [ __ ]
by himself
and um
july 20th i think it came out he texted
me tubes out and i'm like oh my god
[ __ ] he's like i can go home today and
go get the [ __ ] out of here and i can
hear it like it through the text how
happy he is like you know what i mean
like i know how happy is just from the
text like oh my [ __ ] god good [ __ ]
man i'm like i told you it's going to be
good i'm going to go up there and get
the [ __ ] blah blah i got i already
already dropped off the cbd rick simpson
oh i was doing all that stuff doing what
i could
and then
he comes home
from fresno never said he comes home
and i text him like yo you home he goes
sitting on my couch
chilling with my dogs i'm like oh my god
[ __ ]
yes dude he only cares about us his dogs
and guns that's it he's my it's john
that's all he cares about
and
obs for some reason bobby schmerda
he just loves this bobby smirders so
much i told you he introduced me
nicotine and all that [ __ ] but you
wouldn't imagine the bald white guy
with a great beard is just doing this
murder dance all he he only does these
things to make me [ __ ] crack up we'll
be talking and he's like yeah you know
and then just start [ __ ] doing dances
and [ __ ] my job [ __ ] stop it bro
his ultimate signatu his ultimate line
was like i just wanted to see you laugh
he would say i just wanted to see you
laugh because i crack
he's one of the only people that makes
me
tearing [ __ ] laughing because he's a
[ __ ] idiot he's a [ __ ] idiot that
[ __ ] he says i'm gonna punch him in the
[ __ ] stomach
and uh
stop sitting with my dogs on the couch
and he goes pepper had to help me into
the house it was the most embarrassing
thing ever i go john you have [ __ ]
cancer and you had a tube in your chest
it's okay man and he goes i just took a
bite of domino's pizza john i'm so
[ __ ] happy right now he's like i just
drank a soda like he's texting me all
these things because during the hospital
he was eating all that trash food and he
would text me
a piece of pizza right now would be the
best [ __ ] thing ever and he was like
i miss [ __ ] cocaine i miss pizza so
bad
but he hadn't been coaxing for like the
past 10 years since i stopped doing it
he pretty much well i'm not gonna do if
you're not gonna do it that's pretty
much how it was
he's like i [ __ ] miss coke and pizza
he texts me stupid [ __ ] when he he's
trying to make me laugh i mean through
texts and [ __ ] while you're in the
hospital
and then he's texting me i'm like
i am so [ __ ] happy you are at home
right now like i was texting like dude
this is the best thing you could have
said because we weren't sure if he was
leaving the hospital
right
and i'm like yo that's [ __ ] awesome
he's like i'm trying to choke this
[ __ ] pizza down but it's the best
thing i've ever eaten in my damn life i
just drink a [ __ ] dr pepper i just
he's like all hyped up he's like my dogs
are right next to me he's all hyped man
and um my aunt my soul john everything's
like he's home he's home we're gonna
start doing these treatments i'm like
this is the best [ __ ] news and like
an hour and a half later i get this
[ __ ] distress call and [ __ ]
that he started like not breathing he's
like started like
some [ __ ] started happening
on the couch after he stopped after he
was eating pcs like i don't feel good i
can't breathe all this [ __ ] happened so
i think he was having like another heart
attack or some [ __ ] dude but all that
strain from the tube getting into the
sack of his heart
was [ __ ] him up he lost like 70
[ __ ] pounds it looked like
anyway my aunt's like yo we're rushing
the hospital right now and they're like
[ __ ] that we're going to
[Music]
it was in the bay it's like the cardiac
specialist of california or some [ __ ]
and she's like no we're going we're not
going to fresno again [ __ ] that [ __ ] and
they wouldn't take the tube out even
though he asked like i want to go to the
specialist like we can't let you leave
until this tube comes out the tube's not
coming out until that liquid's down he
goes no but i want to leave and go to
the specialist because they misdiagnosed
him for [ __ ] a month
a [ __ ] month you misdiagnosed
somebody you don't really have stage
four lung cancer for a month
[ __ ]
[ __ ] fresno va man
so my aunt's like we're going to this
place blah blah blah we're going like
all right i'm in the car i'm out i'm out
i'm leaving in the morning blah blah
i [ __ ] leave i go get the cbd stuff
again or rso from sacramento and i'm
explaining to him like john just [ __ ]
take this [ __ ] just take it
you're so sick you can't do [ __ ] right
and he's like yeah i'll [ __ ] take it
it's fine give it to your hand i'll do
it she'll stick to the hospital the fact
that we had to sneak in a medicine to
the hospital that'll help him with some
[ __ ]
and then he decided he didn't want to
take it in case it showed up on the test
and they stopped treating him
some
some [ __ ] he was too scared to take
a medicine that would help because the
doctors might go that's not our medicine
get the [ __ ] out
he was too scared to do it
anyway
so here we go um
i'm texting him texting him and texting
him
he's at the hospital with my aunt
and he's like [ __ ] man i was just at
home
i [ __ ] would just wanted to go on my
bed and chill like oh [ __ ] man
you know i was all [ __ ] sad about my
dude it's okay you got to eat some
[ __ ] pizza you got some soda and [ __ ]
go to the doctor and start your
treatments you're going to come right
back home and you're going to [ __ ]
get in shape and you're going to have to
do you know i mean i'm like i said i'm
trying to like this is what's gonna
happen you're gonna be fine you're gonna
be skinny you're gonna be [ __ ] in
shape at least you're scanning i was
just trying to make jokes about it like
ellie
just to make him laugh because he would
do the same for me and um
he's at the hospital and up in the bay
and then everything just went bad man
he was texting me and then my aunt
pepper started texting me because they
finally let her go in and when my uncle
went and saw my aunt finally
he just started getting better
like when they would they would only let
her staying out for two hours a day
the whole day like two hours a day
nobody else
because code restrictions some [ __ ]
so
when he was there the nurse was like oh
his vitals are [ __ ] great
everything's looking good and my aunt
leave and he started going right back
downhill
i believe if they were if if
if they let her stay he would be alive
dude he would have left that place
because i think he gave the [ __ ] up is
what happened i think he was so i'll
tell you why it got bad
so we're there we're staying at the
hotel for a few days i'm texting him and
then it turns into my aunt texting for
him because he he started
something happened dude the [ __ ]
cancer spread to his brain
and those in that those three days this
went through his brain
and he just started going blind he just
couldn't see he's texting me my answer
text me like john says he can't see well
so i'm gonna text for you i'm like all
right tell him this this this this this
and
he lost his whole [ __ ] v all his
vision in a day and a half went away
because his cancer went straight to his
brain and they said we can't do any
procedures until we get his test back on
friday but it's monday and with covert
it might be till next monday and they're
like we can't even treat him so he's
just going to sit here they just like
let my uncle sit there
didn't even treat him because they
wanted to know what type of cancer
i don't know
the medical stuff but i remember i was
pissed
i was really [ __ ] upset
and uh
we're texting i'm telling her like tell
him this tell him this and then my aunt
leaves and comes to the hotel and stays
with us when she's out you know i mean
we're trying to like let's watch
something funny let's do this let's do
that and try to keep our mind off it but
we're staying at the hotel just in case
something happens or he wants to talk to
it we can go right back i mean we're
like [ __ ] that dude we're staying here
and um
he heard like
five days
[ __ ] maybe seven [ __ ]
and um
yeah he went blind
and then the cancer started eating up
his esophagus so he couldn't even eat no
more like he couldn't swallow all his
vocal cords got paralyzed he stopped
talking
he can't talk or see
but he can hear
you see i'm saying
so all this happened in a couple days
like i had a [ __ ] nowhere
all this just started happening back to
back to back to back and i'm sitting
there trying to like no it's fine he's
got it i got him don't worry he's gonna
take this i'm gonna take that we're
gonna laugh about it it's gonna be fine
like we're gonna be like yeah remember
when you almost died [ __ ] oh my
god take care of yourself [ __ ] i told
you stop smoking like i'm trying to
think of like i'm just trying to be like
happy about like ah can't wait to make
fun of this [ __ ]
just to [ __ ] i don't know i'm just i'm
trying not to be upset
and then um
they're like yo you can leave you like
bring food my aunt can bring stuff so i
went and got him
there wasn't any dr pepper's small and i
wanted to chug a two-liter so i got him
like all these orange kiss uh
he collected soda bottles since i was
young he always had all these vintage
soda bottles so i'm like oh i got a sick
one here give this [ __ ] to him but he
couldn't chew or anything so he was like
drinking liquids only so i got him soda
and uh
and my aunt left
came back to the hotel my uncle called
like five minutes later he goes hey it's
seven why aren't you here it's morning
she goes
john i just left dude like it's night
it's gonna be night the sun's coming
going down not coming up
and like you can hear in his voice like
he was like [ __ ]
like you can hear him like just defeated
like bro i thought i had one day gone
it's been 12 minutes because he passed
out with my aunt left right
so all this shit's going on i'm in the
hotel i'm like
all right cool it's gonna be okay [ __ ]
yeah we're fine
and then
it's just getting worse
and then my aunt tells me like yo your
uncle said
like
don't stop him if he decides to not
like not want to be on the machines
anymore or some [ __ ] right like she's
trying to tell me like
he's like you know i'm not a quitter
but this [ __ ] hurts like pretty much
what he said he's like this [ __ ] [ __ ]
hurts i can't breathe i can't see i
can't talk i can't do [ __ ]
but he's talking to my aunt she's like
he i can hear his words but it's like
like he's
barely talking
and i'm like please tell him i said to
shut the [ __ ] up and stop talking like
you know i was like tell him to shut the
[ __ ] up
don't say that [ __ ]
and then
it just kept getting worse like every
[ __ ] hour like every something was
worse man
that monday
something was just worse every [ __ ]
hour he called he's like it's not in the
morning i remember i told you like he's
all defeated and [ __ ]
and i can hear it in his voice and like
oh my god [ __ ]
that's not good i can hear in his voice
he don't ever sound like that
so i can hear his voice
like [ __ ] man
all right i'm going to sleep i'm going
to sleep so i went to bed at the hotel
with rosie
i woke up i went to my aunt's hotel i'm
just waiting there waiting there waiting
there i'm like all right today's date
it's a good day [ __ ] yeah he's gonna be
okay blah blah
and then my aunt because she told me
like if i decide that i don't want to
[ __ ] do this anymore you don't fight
me he was asking her like don't [ __ ]
fight me if i say
please don't [ __ ] fight me because
you know he's like he said it's going to
be so hard for me to say yes take me off
the machine
that it hurts that bad so don't [ __ ]
fight me if i say the [ __ ]
and my aunt's like she's like i told him
yes but i'm not [ __ ] doing that [ __ ]
and then i took a
shower i was getting out of shower
it was like 1 16 i looked at my phone i
was like
drying my hair and i got a call from my
aunt and i don't know why
i was like no what the [ __ ] is going on
and then as soon as like she picks up i
just hear screaming and i'm like [ __ ]
it's done
and um she was like oh he's [ __ ] dead
all this [ __ ]
[ __ ]
and uh
damn it
this is a bad idea
man you're doing great
and uh
i don't know i never felt that i never
felt like
you know my grandma died i had a homie
die
but not someone i'm that close to
i remember i got in the car
i don't remember driving to her hotel at
all
i remember showing up being like
i don't understand
and then
we got to go to his room and that was
the worst [ __ ] thing i ever did my
whole life
and i walked in i saw uncle johnny in
there then that was it
i don't remember much i just remember i
[ __ ] got sick almost fell down
and then
this is not good
because i seen him like that a lot but
he was [ __ ] up with duct tape on his
feet
you know what i mean he wasn't [ __ ]
dead
and then
i remember i'm looking at his body and
i'm like
this is some [ __ ] [ __ ]
i'm like damn your feet are dirty as
[ __ ] still full you've been in a
hospital bed for a month and your feet
are [ __ ] dirty i always made fun of
him because he always wear flip-flops
his feet were black as [ __ ] on the
bottom like john you're so white bro you
gotta
the contrast is [ __ ] not real like
this you gotta stop
clean your feet full all right first
thing i saw you [ __ ] your feet
are dirty as [ __ ]
and i remember i'm like
i wish i never walked in and looked at
looked at this
because i'm sitting there and i'm like
i'm staring i can't like think
i just see him there and i'm like [ __ ]
man
this is [ __ ] [ __ ]
and then i'm like all right hug him
and when i hug i don't think i even told
rosie this [ __ ]
i hugged him and when i hugged him i
heard
like a little
like a wind or something
and i looked at his face and i'm like
no he's not breathing or anything
because she called my 10 minutes after
it happened
so it's not like he was like alive or
anything
but i looked at him
like i'm looking at his [ __ ] eyes
like right here i'm just looking at him
i'm like that's some [ __ ]
i was like i told you i'm gonna get rich
and we're gonna smoke weed on the porch
that was the whole point like we're
gonna get [ __ ] shit-faced we're gonna
be all drinking mick he's just like that
we had like a little thing i'm like i'm
gonna be [ __ ] up on a rocking chair
but i'm gonna be bawling as [ __ ] i would
say this [ __ ] like 16 like i'm gonna be
rich as [ __ ] one day i don't know how
i'm gonna do it be rich and we're gonna
smoke weed out of a big-ass pipe on a
porch and i always just say that [ __ ]
and then i remember i'm looking at him
like this is not gonna happen it's
really not real this is not gonna happen
you're gone this isn't [ __ ]
and i remember i don't know how much
time passed
but they couldn't even give him the
[ __ ] soldier thing they had to walk
him around the [ __ ] ho the hospital
with a flag on his [ __ ]
because they didn't do the gun thing is
kovit
and i remember
my sister came i got her i'm like
so the message is a dick but my yell
full
if i were you if i could go back and you
win first i wouldn't go in i told her
i'm like if you want to go and go in
i wouldn't go in there
and she's like i'm going in anyway i'm
like
all right [ __ ]
you [ __ ] asked for it
and she walked in i'm like
yup
that is that what you wanted like is
that what you wanted to [ __ ] see i
[ __ ] try to warn your ass don't do it
because i regret it the second i walked
it i just got like
i couldn't breathe i felt like i was
gonna fall i just might put my hand on
some machine thing i was like trying to
stand up i just felt like i never felt
like i couldn't move before i was just
like if i was gonna throw up and i
couldn't breathe and i couldn't yell
i don't know i don't know how to explain
it never felt that before
and i get to the parking lot
i look at rosie i'm like what the [ __ ]
is going on
i couldn't i didn't believe it was i
could not [ __ ] believe this [ __ ]
because it's not he can do anything
about it i couldn't do nothing about it
that's it it's over it's gone
you cannot help anymore
and then uh
that's [ __ ] it
i left
i hadn't drank soda in four years
because i'm addicted and i went and got
a coke because it's his favorite thing
in the world to [ __ ] drink as a as a
[ __ ] coke in a bottle and i went and
got one
i chugged and it hurt so bad
and i bought a mickey's and i chugged it
it was disgusting
but i drove home and his [ __ ] he always
wore an orange shirt and he was bald as
[ __ ] i'm like you're like [ __ ] the
sun
i used to tell them like you like the
sun with that [ __ ] well you just wear a
shirt
o.j simpson
drink apple juice because oj will kill
you and he was like oh jason
he used to wear it all the time like
well you have the [ __ ] sun
and we drove home and as we were driving
home at night the moon was bright orange
don't know why
i have it on tape
it's bright and my favorite [ __ ] was
orange like that's what like he was
always well he was more orange shirt and
that [ __ ] was bright [ __ ] orange i'm
like what the [ __ ]
that's why like there's no orange moon
never seen one the day five [ __ ]
hours after you [ __ ] die and i leave
okay
cool
and then
bro that was it
and i can't believe it we didn't even
have a funeral
because it covered we had a memorial
two days ago
it'll wait that long
and uh
august 5th
i had a dream
like you know i have wild dreams
august 5th i had a dream
someone's knocking on the door of a
house i didn't recognize
and i went open the door
and john's standing there like this
he was always smoking he was smoking
like this
and he's looking at me like that side
eye
and i look at him and i'm like
wait am i in a [ __ ] dream
because i'm like am i a [ __ ] dream
could i dream that jon died and this is
real
you know what i'm saying like because i
was in such a [ __ ] weird
[ __ ] i didn't know what was going on
like i was just i never felt shocked
before or like
you know that feeling like if i can rip
my chest open and just explode i would
you know like that feeling of like i
don't know what to do i don't know what
to do somebody shoot me i don't know
what the [ __ ]
you got feeling like i don't know what
to do with my next breath type [ __ ]
so i was like uh is this a [ __ ] real
dream and then my grandma dolores and my
grandpa tom were standing next to him
uh look he goes
can i come in oh yeah [ __ ] the [ __ ]
and he walked in and my grandma and my
grandpa walked in
and i closed the door and i woke up that
was it and i talked to jebus two nights
ago my one of my best friends and he had
to say almost the same dream about john
he's like a couple days after he told me
he died i had a dream of some random
house
like we were all waiting for you
open the door
and like you were coming in with some
people and john was waiting with me i'm
like did you recognize that you guys
know it's all weird i had a dream just
like that i didn't know what house it
was
but i opened the door but in his dream
john has opened the door for me i'm like
what
weird dream
and dude that's [ __ ] it
i didn't know any of those
funny thing though
i bet him when memphis was like a couple
months old like [ __ ]
18. yeah you're never fixing that
[ __ ] car
so the last [ __ ] time i went to his
house i was like
he's like one smoke he's like no i all
right now like you know i'm cuz his mom
leave him she's elderly and [ __ ]
he's like no i gotta do her things right
now i'm like oh it's all good bro i'm
gonna leave you some weed blah blah and
i headed back to la
[ __ ] sold the car
didn't tell me
that's why he was avoiding showing
because the new house i'm like yo new
house i haven't seen it yet it's right
when kova started because they just
bought a house mike show me the house
and he didn't show me the garage and i
didn't think about why don't you show me
the garage it's because the [ __ ]
buick's not there and he didn't want to
like
i owe you a hundred dollars
[ __ ] i owe you a hundred dollars
and i'm right
day night he died i'm like where's
john's pie
where's his wheat pie i want to go smoke
in the garage
yeah i mean i was like no i got to sit
by the car and smoke smoke weed like we
always did and i open the door i go
where the [ __ ] is the car
i look to pepper she goes
oh [ __ ] he told me not to tell you
oh he told you not to tell me
he sold it a couple months ago he's like
i'm never gonna [ __ ] fix it i'm not
i'm over it
the [ __ ] took 17 years to decide
to give me my hundred dollars and then
the [ __ ] guy was like i'm gonna die
first forgive you [ __ ] hundred
dollars and he did that [ __ ]
dude but i also bet him that my cousin
would be six six by the time he was 18.
he's only six five
so i would it would have been a wash i
would owe him a hundred dollars too so
you'd have to die to get out of the
[ __ ] bet john all right you'd have to
do all this
um
and that's the funny thing that ended
that night i remember thinking like
you little [ __ ]
we had a long lifetime back on you
[ __ ] and i said memphis turns 18
in two weeks
and like
weird
how odd
so anyway full swindled me the last
thing he ever did was [ __ ] swindle me
dude
god man that [ __ ]
that's it man what a story god damn i
had no idea any of this was going on
even in real time as all that was
happening
there's no need yeah
i'm trying to deal with it but
it was all bad man but anyway i don't
like to think of those last months but
the only thing that sucks is all you
fools that can be deleted on instagram
and all that [ __ ] i have to go get a new
ip address and a new phone you guys
[ __ ] played me i lost all my text
from him i had to get a new [ __ ]
phone and when i activated it all the
pictures are there no text so all of our
[ __ ] two years of dumb [ __ ] is gone
can't even get it back
that's the one thing that pisses me off
like all the stupid [ __ ] he would send
me is gone because somebody wants to get
me [ __ ] deleted and [ __ ] that's never
happened i used to keep my text but
something happened with a phone like
malfunction and i didn't get my text
back when i did the new phone
so stop reporting me i lost all my text
man that's the one thing i'm pissed
about i would give like 10 bands to get
those texts back mm-hmm
i mean [ __ ] maybe icloud or something
i have like four different iclouds
because all the times i've been deleted
new emails knew this do that do this do
that but what goes to what what goes to
what is before i was organized
write down a piece of papers my new
password all right cool
try to hurry up make it for there's 10
[ __ ] fake accounts yeah like i'm
speeding to the [ __ ] store by all
right so there's ready five fake
accounts like i don't want people
getting swindled for packs so i'm like
no make my account right now it's
official post on your page rosie that's
how we make it official like she post my
page my new page my snapchat my [ __ ]
youtube
because people will make a fake account
right off the bat so anyway that's not
it's irrelevant but
yes
i lost all my text messages
whack
as [ __ ]
anyway
that's the story
hell of a tribute on the first year
yep
[ __ ] john
it just sucks though i don't have that
person anymore
um i don't have that guy he's going to
be my best man
did he get to see the podcast take off
or hold on let me i'm trying to i'm
trying to do the time february we
started oh he was asking me every how's
the podcast what's up with the set oh
you're going to get that warehouse are
you gonna sign the thing are you gonna
because we were looking for where i was
like when are you gonna get it where are
you gonna get it at all he was up to
down every [ __ ] thing i was ever
doing he was on that [ __ ]
but he knew about rose i mean he
proposed to rosie nice he's the only
person that knew though
i was supposed to propose her in like
[ __ ] eight months before but that
[ __ ] happened i was like i am not trying
to propose to you sad as [ __ ]
but i just started getting normal like
two months ago it's just [ __ ] every
time i think about it i have such a good
memory that i go all right let's go to
scene one hey man you look like saber
tooth and it just plays over and over
and over all the way when i'm trying to
sleep i go from every house we've ever
hung out and every time i can and it's
just never i can't ever fall asleep
that's the only bad part it's like [ __ ]
man
i can't sleep because i'm just thinking
about this for all [ __ ] time
um
but yeah that's the story man
one of my best homies ever
he was so cool he was so [ __ ] dumb he
said the dumbest [ __ ] in the [ __ ] i
i'm not the only one that's gonna say
that everybody in my family knows that
john says the dumbest [ __ ]
i just loved it i loved in public he
would say the dumbest [ __ ]
but anyway his [ __ ] mom passed away
like a couple weeks later
and she was living my aunt so my aunts
[ __ ] got it bad dude
shot everything all at once
um but things are getting better dude
things get better my cousin just
graduated high school he's about turn
18.
he went to the army when i was getting
out he [ __ ] died right before memphis
goes gets out like
the timing with this guy
[ __ ] john that's that's the only
shitty part it's like [ __ ] man i just
want to smoke a bull with this [ __ ]
so bad i just want to [ __ ] smoke a
ball with him
or something or drink one i don't know i
don't know you know what i'm saying
[ __ ] it's just trash
i can't believe how long that story took
money we're supposed to do an hour and a
half i'm sorry
it's so long
i feel like the fans have been wondering
about those too
yeah not fun
man [ __ ] i mean it's part of life we've
got a yeah i mean i know i didn't expect
it so really yeah
come on
that [ __ ] early
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
hey man kobe went out at 41 last year
hmm
damn
i remember thinking with kobe bryant's
like damn here's my age man that's crazy
and he told me that i'm like dude don't
be 41 what the [ __ ] say i know bro he's
my [ __ ] age that's so sad
[ __ ] months later his fool's gone
it's a trip because i know you went
through that [ __ ] too
yeah big time but for forever yeah
yeah yeah yeah the [ __ ] with my dad took
forever but some there was a lot of
similarities with his lung cancer too
huh
yeah
uh i mean not he probably quit smoking
cigarettes when i was like five
so same ten years later
oh 15. yeah yeah i guess so i mean my
uncle sasebo 10 year 10 years later he
got cancer yeah i think it's from the
fields in iraq though yeah
i don't know what happened with my dad
my dad didn't we didn't really talk so
he like communicated everything through
my ma to me like even when i found out i
mean he didn't really talk to me
so like i mean we didn't yeah we didn't
really talk all like that
from the time i was probably like 12.
so he would like talk through my ma so i
like i remember when i i was walking
down this uh i got off the school bus
and both cars were there and i was like
damn something's wrong
and then i walked down your mommy that
separated no
no but they were both they were never
both there when i got home that was like
the only time ever oh
so uh yeah and then he was just like
wait why don't you go upstairs your
mom's got something to tell you
and then she was like yeah he's got you
know stage four cancer whatever
it didn't speak to you i mean it wasn't
like he
didn't
like it wasn't a choice he dunked on him
once he was like i am never talking
again no
i don't know what it was he just kind of
like odd relationship yeah i don't know
1950s
it was kind of like that it was i mean
he was a straight-up hippie and his dad
was like a
you know straight out of ireland like
they called him the giant like he was uh
you know he had a really tough
reputation or whatever about
i don't know he just doing he just did
his own thing
we just you know he always communicated
to me through my mind i remember that
that's how i found out when i found out
i didn't even really react
you know but i remember like the next
day in school they announced it over the
[ __ ] about your dad yes why
because they it was uh i was going to
the saint francis it was i just started
going to the school i transferred to a
private school in 10th grade for
basketball and i went in there i was new
i didn't know any of this [ __ ] and over
the loudspeakers they said
please pray for o'neil's dad who's
diagnosed with cancer all this [ __ ] so
they were like the teacher when that
happened was like oh [ __ ] and he's like
don't you go you can go sit and like
they put me in like a storage closet
literally i'd be pissed
i was sitting in this closet like not
even i wasn't i don't even know how i
was like i was
obviously upset that they just did that
because now forevermore now you're the
kid that everybody's your dad's dying
huh yeah
sorry
but yeah so i mean that that went on for
uh you know it was just because he was
supposed to die then like it was like
he's gonna die no doubt about it but he
didn't and then that happened like for
years right yeah that kept happening
though where the doctors were like
writing them off
and you'd have these horrible surgeries
and then you'd come back
so like yeah it was like
eight years of that
you know like he was the longest
surviving person in the whole cancer
hospital from the cancers he had and all
this [ __ ] but
yeah we didn't really talk we weren't
close like how you're describing we and
he smoked weed too that was the thing
he's just stealing his weed how is he a
hippie he was a musician basketball
rapping yeah musician he was like he saw
me getting all like you know like how i
was and [ __ ] when i was 12 and he i
think he probably just
was like damn i raised jamie kennedy
[ __ ]
and uh was that movie again
was one enough
yeah basically i think that's kind of
what it was not dear mama yeah exactly
wow you [ __ ] nailed it
jesus christ
[Music]
smoke on the water not lethal injection
yeah oh wow
that one oh man
that was the case though but i get it
but damn marty's dead but especially
when i started doing music though
because i was like he was looking at me
like this [ __ ] you got we're two
recording artists living in the same
house we don't even talk about it i'm
going to the same studios that he used
to go to learning about him from the
engineers asking what yeah
i don't i mean he tried to when i was
younger he tried to teach me keyboard he
wanted me he wanted probably nothing
more than for me to learn guitar i was
into [ __ ] tupac and eminem and [ __ ]
i was rapping i was on some
g-unit type of [ __ ] he was looking at me
crazy she should have just embraced that
[ __ ] yeah he i mean he let me use his
little equipment here and there but at
the same time i knew he was embarrassed
i knew like he looked at his
he looked at me and my boy is like jesus
[ __ ] christ
but at the same time i all looking back
if i would have been him i would have
handled it completely differently for
sure and i would have gave my kid a
heads up like you know the [ __ ] you're
getting yourself into out here like your
homies you're chilling with
they're wild yeah
just letting you know
none of that heads up there was
zero heads up on any even when i had a
even when i'm like i'm having a kid
it wasn't even really like
i don't i don't know it was just was did
wasn't that we weren't like that i'm not
closing my dad either really yeah but
even i mean you gotta imagine this man
he was like sick for so long he never
talked about it talk to you and go your
mom has something to say to you yeah i
remember that vividly i mean i don't
know i don't know what it's like to
break that news but you that was also
just the routine that was just normal
too at the same time
yeah and i remember i didn't even say
anything i was like i just got my
license and i was like
all right i'm gonna go play basketball
i just that was one of the first times i
drove by myself i went and took it and
[ __ ] just went and shot with my boy
khalil like yeah he's got cancer and
[ __ ]
but i didn't know what that meant i
didn't know like oh he's he's probably
about to die
but man he [ __ ] fought though it was
horrible really really horrible
but then there he got moments of his
life back too yeah i mean he got to have
a final like party like we had this huge
party at this uh brewery in downtown
buffalo when they knew like for for sure
it wasn't looking good
and he released a cd like i did the
artwork all the [ __ ] they did
a big [ __ ] concert and [ __ ]
yeah so he got i mean he like had a
send-off wow yeah many people get that
yeah
but then when they then he like shortly
thereafter they started putting him on
the real medicine and like you're saying
like he would start he was like starting
to trip out and [ __ ]
so that you know there was definitely a
point where it was like when roswell
came in this like you could see like
this is different now
and then our dog we had to put my dog
down like two weeks before he died and
him and my dog were best friends my
friends used to tease me because him and
the dog were so close
literally
so that was the dog more than you marty
he was like that was that was the only
time i ever saw him cry anything it was
like the dog died i walked in he didn't
even say anything he just like put his
head down he was dying it was a real
moment oh man i had to wear the red fern
grows
yeah
but he got to meet my daughter and stuff
i was aware of that i was aware like i
was only 20 21 or whatever but i was
like damn you got to see me become a man
you're like i was old enough to be i was
a dad and i was starting to look like
damn we don't really like i would have
given me a lot of more advice as a dad
but
yeah the night the night that so we were
it was [ __ ] up i was thinking about
this earlier
we knew he was probably gonna pass away
it had been lingering for eight years
i needed to make something happen in
life
and we had an opportunity to go live
right outside of new york city with
april's aunt for free she was like come
stay with us for a couple months save up
we're trying to get out here
save up
you can make your move buy your house we
knew we had to get out of buffalo so i
was like all right i'll make this fast
we were going to move to new jersey it
was snowing april's dad who never comes
up and visits us from he lives hours
away want to watch the podcast yes shout
out
he came up and helped us move on the ice
in a blizzard we pack up the u-haul
we're getting ready to go to new jersey
the next day
so you know my my dad's sick but he's
he's home with my ma
you know we're getting ready to make
this life move i got to make something
happen in life period
so
this is what i'm dealing with
uh so
yeah we pack up all our [ __ ] we go out
to april's to dinner with april's family
like you know like kind of like a
send-off dinner then we stop back at my
mom's house and lock one on the way home
to say goodbye to them april goes in to
go to first to go to the bathroom she
goes in and then she goes my dad's like
laying on the bed or whatever and she
goes in and says something to him he's
like conscious you know lets him know
like
ariana's here marty's here or whatever
she leaves then i go in i stayed in the
car cause ariana is still a baby and
we're in the driveway
so then i go in and then when i go in
he's dead
so same exact thing i walk in realize it
dry heaving out on the porch
all that
and then
wait in those few seconds yeah
yeah like he acknowledged her
and then when she came in sat in the car
with ariana and i went in is when we
realized he was dead
so you know
that [ __ ] was crazy
so then
yeah we got he had a little music studio
he taught guitar so he hit a music
studio it was a duplex the upper
apartment was a music studio so he's
still in the house i go up in the music
studio i got his guitar strap on my
shoulder i'm sitting with april april's
dad
had went home
he had helped us move
april's dad had never called me before
in life mind you my dad's still in the
house
i get a voicemail from her dad
april's got a cell phone the phone
didn't even ring i just got a voicemail
from her dad and he goes i just want to
let you know i made it home safe i'm
good
uh whatever whatever
and it was just like
whoa trippy chills
i didn't even know it was him he had
never called me before
but it was april's dad
so then yeah that [ __ ] was crazy
so then like yeah about a week we had
all the services and all this [ __ ] and
like my mom wanted to be left alone so
we kept we kept about a week later we
went to [ __ ] new jersey i drove all
of our [ __ ] to new jersey
and i remember vividly having a mom
i remember i was i was smoking a joint
on the way to
driving back upstate new york no middle
of nowhere really just by myself all of
our [ __ ] ton of pressure on the line too
we're going to april's family's house
so i'm driving
and uh
over the hills i see a bunch of cop cars
i'm smoking a joint like
i got all of our [ __ ] in the back i'm
going to april's family's house ugh
i throw the drone out the window i'm
going up and down hills i [ __ ] might
remember my phone falls off my lap i
just get my [ __ ] together i roll down
the window
what do you need she looks in
nothing keep it going
jesus [ __ ] christ and i just rolled
the window up they just had a little
checkpoint going
but that would have been over i mean we
would have had not a place to go
so then yeah man we got down to new
jersey after about three months i got my
life i got my license in this insurance
[ __ ] i was going to build up i was
working for this dude gonna build up all
this [ __ ]
and then i just realized one day after
like two or three months
this is not it like i had this whole
story with travis barker all this crazy
[ __ ] happened and
we came right back to buffalo i set my
sights in california and it was you know
not that probably we got married another
year and then we were out here whoa yeah
so wild night you never told me about uh
how your dad passed yeah he had cancer
but
yeah that [ __ ] was crazy
yeah it really was it was it was as you
walk up the porch basically yeah
yeah so april was the last one he talked
to or the last person that like talked
to him
but i mean he knew we were there and all
that so
yeah this [ __ ] was crazy
oh my god but we were like me and my
like
you know air quotes brother jamel during
his service we were like laughing the
whole time not like how you were saying
we were like making jokes
it was weird thinking about it now we
were like in the church literally the
whole in the front row laughing the
whole [ __ ] time
just like cracking jokes and [ __ ] back
and forth through each other like
the way you're talking about john
reminds me of how me and him were why
were you
i mean that's just how we it's just how
it was it was a [ __ ]
funeral they had his guitar up on the
[ __ ]
center of the church thing
i don't know that's all i remember
wow yeah
yeah yeah but
[ __ ] got sugar gotcha she got real
real after that
and
a lot of [ __ ] happened and then i ended
up deciding i was a [ __ ] lone wolf in
life and
left left
bro yeah a lot of stories in there so
much for this hour and a half mark
closing on three hours now [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ]
that's wild man i did not know that
that's insane
what are you gonna do
nothing
yeah it's been 10 years what a couple
months ago like a month ago
yeah it was 10 years
the day we did what
put out the podcast
or something like that the way that it
landed it was like my super bowl
commercial i filmed that's what it was
one day then it wasn't birthday birthday
and then it was the start of the podcast
and then the day down and then the next
day was the day he died like february
6th 7th 8th 9th this year yes yes that's
what it was all wild as [ __ ]
i don't know man uh
what a sad ass episode man
god
people gotta deal with this
[Music]
only some of you will get that reference
all right and for those of you that do
high [ __ ] five
kids gotta go through this [ __ ] without
having and a lot of people that even
people i listened to and looked up to
growing up
wouldn't put this type of [ __ ] out there
necessarily yeah sit here and [ __ ] no
it's not i was never going to talk about
this [ __ ] and randomly i'm like
we're filming on the day um today's the
day it's only right it's a day
yeah when my mom tried to bring up like
bishop but you bringing that [ __ ] up
right now like [ __ ] that all in one word
too mm-hmm
cause i ain't ready to talk about that
[ __ ] yeah everything i did today i
wasn't even ready to talk about that
[ __ ]
i didn't want to talk about everything
yeah
but yeah man now you conveyed that man
sure way it went man
some
[ __ ]
puts things in perspective for kids and
[ __ ] it's weird
super weird
but yeah dude what a weird podcast
episode
started off all let's get interactive
and every time i looked at the clock i'm
like it's been 30 more minutes huh
[ __ ] john
i as i think like damn
that was fast
well
he would not be proud of me for three
hours and took one grenade
[Laughter]
all right man
great episode sir yeah probably what
else to talk about
i think i think we're good
we're stocking up with some big guests
coming up true and you're in this
camera's dude okay i just saw it right
now
um
shout out to the sponsors
shout out to on it get in shape while
you're sad
don't lose your hair don't lose your
hair
over the loved ones
what else oh sorry on it and keep are
you gonna work manscaped into this one
yo you ever had a loved one pass away
well i bet you they cut their balls too
i'll [ __ ] flip it i don't think i
will [ __ ] get it somehow
it'll work
it's like a rapper like yo i'll make any
rhyme anything around [ __ ] like
rhyme orange
orange
orange you glad
i know that's the only word you can't
rhyme with right
unless you have a southern accent and it
just sounds like something else
[Music]
yeah dude i uh
randomly man i don't know why don't know
why my uncle loved
bobby schmurder so much in kodak black
but he did he really did for some reason
and i love i love kodak black so much
everybody's like hey man one day i won't
get caught at black on the show and you
go i don't think i would expect you to
say that to me
oh i love ignorant ass music bro i don't
think you understand the [ __ ] that
you're like what the [ __ ] did he say
that's that [ __ ] uh-huh
just some southern i love southern
rappers man oh my god that accent is
just makes it so so so hannah huh oh
we're
[Applause]
talking about this new [ __ ] and you go
back to [ __ ] 400 degrees i love that
[ __ ] though like that's when my uncle
john my uncle i found his mixtape and
mixed cds the other day oh my [ __ ]
god it brought back some memories he's a
super he was a super uh old country
george jones
fan and [ __ ] like that like he's into
the old country new every [ __ ]
country artist ever
like you can name say a song by oh by
something something like so his music
and movies were so vast that's where i
got all my [ __ ] from
it's weird to think about but besides
adam sandler and like xi jin chong
everything else is my uncle john
i know like every other movie i've ever
[ __ ] owned
yeah weird
and uh
he loved juvenile
and he loved [ __ ] looney collion i
don't know if you know who luna called
thug real mccoy
but yeah
uh
he's hard and mad ignorant i love that
[ __ ] and that's where i learned all my
[ __ ] from so
do now
i love that [ __ ] i love southern rappers
rapping um there's this other rapper i
don't know why we're talking about this
i just
there's this rapper my homie justin from
pittsburgh show me name valley v-a-l-e-e
i think vale valley
i don't know why i love it so much but
i've been listening to the same like
four songs for about two days
i don't know what about it i don't know
what it is about that voice that makes
me go sick it's just like a little baby
voice
why are we talking about this right i
don't know i have no idea yeah listen i
checked out uh rachaelton's [ __ ] that
[ __ ]
yeah it's pretty [ __ ] hard even if
you don't understand what he's saying
like when you just did that that that
ticky ticky tock though oh that [ __ ]
yeah uh
fool omar's music's hard yeah that's
true stop april april grew up on that
[ __ ] reggaeton she heard it she was
like what the [ __ ] is this oh yeah bro
play that in a nightclub and you're like
oh see every girl get up and damn like
all right omar good [ __ ] man like some
of the uh my favorite one is like where
the beat leads you here
and it's like a trap [ __ ]
it's just so sick a lot of the [ __ ] he's
done is dumb tight
um
but yeah
it's ham dude what an episode i'm
talking about [ __ ] random rappers too
good [ __ ]
but oh cause john yeah he introduced me
to so much [ __ ] so much so much music
man
um yeah man i think that's i think
that's everything everything we wanted
to talk about today what an episode it
was all the way through
yeah hell yeah it's gonna be a big month
we got
some big decisions we're making about
the show right now
yep and uh we got a big episode book for
the end of the month that everyone's
very excited about should we talk about
it i think we could talk i think i mean
goblin pose on twitter
might as well yeah so we're gonna do our
first two epis uh two guest episode
we're gonna have uh me over here
and we're gonna have goblin and we're
gonna have eric kahn we're gonna do it
all
the same episode in the same episode
three mics going let's [ __ ] get it
let's see how this goes man
this time
i'm just gonna roll the most joints
i mean million subscriber style
not that fat because we don't want
people yeah
oh so when i was six oh
you know what i mean like so when i was
seven
i'm just going to roll
vast amounts of joints
and we're going to have a good time
it's going to be fun
uh yeah aircon uh
goblin episode for everyone that keeps
asking for x code a i talk to him he
does not like to get on planes
oh
maybe he'll flip and he'll be like yeah
i want to come out there but yeah i hit
him up he says next time he's out in l.a
he's like i don't really travel that
much i don't want to [ __ ] with planes i
don't [ __ ] planes either we're
talking about final destination devon
sawwa i don't [ __ ] with planes either
but so i feel you but yeah i asked him
guys so you guys you guys ask a lot so
you don't have to ask anymore whenever
he's out here he says he'll do it i'm
[ __ ] i hyped sean o'malley coming
we're trying to get nate diaz nick diaz
kevin smith
stephen uh stevo
i
i really want to talk to warren sapp you
remember warren sapp oh yeah
so i be him and reggie white were the
only fools i was like
oh these [ __ ] the position i
played both of them well reggie white
was a tackle but still
yeah warren south smokes weed
yeah i want to get high warren sapp
that'd be cool
yeah i got your rookie car [ __ ]
i do have it [ __ ] in a little case
and everything
um but yeah there's a bunch there's a
bunch of people we want to talk to you
guys there's a lot of people uh we want
to get on the show
but we'll get to that later and i think
we should wrap it up it's been three
[ __ ] hours what a weird i feel like i
did drugs
like i feel like i'm coming off a
mushroom or something when you say some
[ __ ] like this out loud for the first
time it's your brain is like i feel
weird like i'm a little like lost or
some [ __ ] maybe it's the beer i haven't
drank forever but it's only one
doesn't even see how many ounces they
don't give a [ __ ]
12 ounce beer
it looks like a little ginger ale or
something it's a little grenade mickey's
grenade
i feel less irish for not knowing what
the [ __ ] that is mickey's boy the 40s
are better though i only hold him at the
top
this is the best way to hold a 40. i
don't know understand why i see
everybody else with the bag and [ __ ]
i see movies too [ __ ] hold it at
the top nothing else gets hot
yeah you don't get your beer hot yeah no
i walk around like [ __ ] puff daddy
with my bottle of champagne yeah
yo puff daddy bro
we got to get out of here but real quick
one time rosie and i we used to go to
the spa this facial spot for covid and
rosie really loves puff daddy and then
one time rosie went to the [ __ ] spa
and they shut the spa down because
somebody was coming in with their
security and rosie's in the [ __ ]
sauna
and puff daddy and his wife
walk in and their security's like
all right you could stay
tell rosie she's in the sauna because
they blocked off the [ __ ] doors like
nobody else could come in here [ __ ] that
security stand out the door and [ __ ]
and rosie chill with puff daddy like an
hour and she taught him about vegan
stuff because he was trying to go vegan
no [ __ ] yeah you're showing a vegan
party and she's like yeah so you can
make this like you can make cheese out
of nuts
i can only imagine just
give me some cheesecake you can make
cheese out of nuts
i want you to walk down to new york city
or whatever the [ __ ] i always go puff
daddy but dave chappelle playing
when he hits vegan cambodian breast milk
exactly
yeah exactly
damn like six references uh so yeah
rosie got uh trapped in a sauna but like
in a cool way and then she shot to chill
with somebody she she [ __ ] loves her
i knew that too she loves buff daddy
she's like he's so tight
and she just chilled with him and his
wife like an hour by herself and was
like yeah and then she called me you're
not gonna [ __ ] believe and then one
time we were coming to the spa i was
waiting for outside because i got done
first and i'm like yo was that ellen
holy [ __ ] sick
and then rosie texts me like yo
and she's telling the whole story like
i've turned around i was paying my bill
like knocked into some dude hella hard
after all the bad and
he was like oh no i'm sorry sorry sorry
it's okay but it was [ __ ] justin
bieber i was like who's that helen
because i just saw blonde i'm skinny in
a hoodie i'm like yo elle is sick
she was like
[ __ ]
it was just
it was just
why we talk about this oh puff daddy
yeah i just thought it was funny i
looked at rosie and saw her like yeah i
got to tell the story real quick she was
so high you're not gonna [ __ ] wait yo
some people pay 100 racks for that
consultation [ __ ] you should have paid
you
party party planner
no but puff daddy's tight anyway yeah i
hold puff daddy ding ding ding
sirac
um yo we gotta get out of here for
everyone on the road i'm [ __ ] sorry
and if you kept up with me yo don't
drink and drive that's crazy
i don't advocate drinking and driving i
don't advocate smoking and driving
do you like that wink for everyone
oh
bro don't do that to me
you've been saving it the whole episode
i can see it in your face
i got a headache behind my left eyebrow
marty
instantly oh we got some new ones loaded
up folks yeah yeah that gunshot last
time sincerely scared me um ariana
thought that was so funny that siren
[ __ ] me up right now too
you know why all i see is red on the
screen from the [ __ ] mics being
recorded so all i see is like red bars
so i hear first live well [ __ ]
that again ain't nothing illegal in here
[ __ ] but still it's just it's
the habit no it's the people in their
cars that really [ __ ]
you're a dick
yeah you gotta that used to happen in
mixtapes you're an ass so i didn't think
about that so right now you hear me talk
and you hear me oh you're right now
hey man mark
and drive one other thing
you know you always go what kind of what
a dick bro he's got the [ __ ] cop car
right around the cop car marty's got a
cop car
marty's got a cop car too
that's what he rides in so every time
you see one of those guys like oh he's a
cop no just high ass marty oh you're
talking about the truck yeah i know i
feel like a [ __ ] car has the cops in
california the same suv yeah bro every
time you pull up
like smarty mike
right yeah i know you like that
girl you're scaring [ __ ]
pulling up on the freeway uh-huh
yes it's [ __ ] high [ __ ] i'm not a cop
oh yeah get the [ __ ] out of the way
i'm more scared of you seriously
yeah that's hilarious i've definitely
considered that yeah
let's pull up yeah you got the [ __ ]
clean cut white dude
oh he looked away
[Music]
yo um i did this whole podcast with no
shoes on what a weirdo it was so hot in
here that marty's like you stick your
shoes off it's hot i am wearing high top
vans that's probably true yeah and uh
since that we're gonna be changing
studios we're building a new studio all
right
in with the new changing studios we have
a whole other section this warehouse is
not used we realize that we're [ __ ]
it's too hot yeah too hot it's dusty
it's simply too [ __ ] hot in here it's
too hot it's what time is it 12
yeah
it's midnight that's how we have to do
this guys because that's how hot it is
oh i got to be back here in a few hours
that's how i feel all right we gotta end
it dude we gotta end it
what a podcast but anyway the shot's
still gonna look sick and it's just oh
yeah there it is it's gonna be in the
next room same set we're doing the exact
same thing rebuilding it just
that way
in there we realized brand new
we have an office suite with ac
plenty of room we just thought we need
more room we don't need more [ __ ]
room already
all that's going to be different is
we're right here yeah
it's just going to be cooler here yeah
and it's not 104
yeah
yeah and there was dust coming in so i
had the owners block all the airways
yeah so it's in real and we have to take
the cameras down and set them back up
each time each time it takes two hours
we have to reset the entire set every
[ __ ] time so i go we're gonna be at
six oh we'll start today okay
two hours and we gotta break down
we don't need the space it's gonna be a
lot more efficient it's gonna be cooler
yeah and we have like traditional for
gas and lighting in the in the walls
this time yes
we're gonna put lighting in the set
instead of having
everything out it's going to be cool
um
but yeah we're getting a new set guys
we're going to do that i think the 20th
and uh yeah it's going to be great
guests won't be sweating balls dude i
felt bad for josh josh wolf came and he
was glistening yeah
glistening
oh yeah i could see on his face people
thought he was just high or some [ __ ] no
it is a thousand degrees in here [ __ ]
hot here you guys don't know this but
there's a full-on fan on white noise
mode underneath me
all right there's a fan on my legs with
no shoes on because that's how hot it is
it's like a little nicky out here but
flipped
all right i'm out here trying to cool my
lower legs off
and uh
yo we gotta stop ranting it's the beer
[ __ ] drink malt liquor to stand
in front of buildings all day and talk
now i know why yeah [ __ ] out
here standing in front of liquor stores
drinking the small liquids
yo what up yeah i can do that too if i
had nothing to do that's how i feel
right now i'm just talking about [ __ ]
nothing i'm sorry if you're driving
marty scared me with the lights then we
talked about the set
allen iverson all right elena
practice that's how i feel right now you
should have practiced this before we did
it
i didn't
we just talked about a story i haven't
talked about yet
that's how i feel right now man hold on
i gotta i want to be careful right here
all right what
we got we got some new sounds loaded up
i don't even [ __ ] around and hit the
wrong ones oh one's just like my address
or something
what could it possibly be barney has a
whole nother life or just a bunch of
[ __ ] crazy political things
oh okay i knew it was coming still scary
we got the funk flex
we got
i don't [ __ ] with that purge
that sounds evil
we got
what are you [ __ ] nuts
is that chucky [ __ ]
bro what are you doing to me
we gotta chuck you up the thing i hate
about chucky the most is his voice and
you know that
and you got the most human part that's
the worst part marty i was like marty
when we do shrooms this month
we go on the trip i'm going to scare you
not while you're on shrooms all right
but i'm going to scare you i couldn't i
could have saved the [ __ ]
disgusting
i was trying to think
i heard the voice and went
why did that take me back to going like
this
and i knew i'm like oh that's chucky i
know that [ __ ] voice
that was genuine [ __ ] childhood
furious
you guys see this [ __ ]
you guys see this [ __ ] oh he loves it so
much i hope it's a split screen right
now i spit everywhere right now
[ __ ] man that was some [ __ ] gunshots
really scared you
a couple of them were genuine this one
you're like
i knew that was the voice that was so
[ __ ] nasty
i think the guy that tried to molest you
when you're a kid and you're hearing me
oh [ __ ] that's how i feel like yo you
tormented me every [ __ ] day my dad
[ __ ] with me with him everybody made
fun of me that's the that's my childhood
trauma is that voice right there
i just compared it to be yeah i did
it's the podcast
it's a podcast if you weren't ready for
that
then you're [ __ ] late bro i said
stupid [ __ ]
all right that's just stupid [ __ ] and
i did just compare it but it was trauma
you meant that [ __ ] i meant that [ __ ]
ew marty
ew sorry all right we won't bust out
chucky nasty
nasty
ugh
that's all the new ones thank you thank
you
he was doing this for everyone
oh no we're done i was in suspense
waiting for like my mom
why the [ __ ] did you pick up why didn't
you mow the [ __ ] lawn
oh [ __ ] oh you didn't mow the lawn
get out of here man
another one like sir she's pregnant oh
that's a scary one too you should yo for
depending on which guess we should [ __ ]
with i've been thinking about this i
know marty some custom hey
be that best producer in the planet
award and start [ __ ] with the guests
and don't tell me that you're going to
[ __ ] with them
the best producer in the flat of the
world
best producer on the planet also marty
once got punched by some rapper because
he played some childhood trauma to it
yeah i could i could tell all right say
no more
we're gonna get y'all rolling here this
is gonna be 50 cent five minute water
and drywall is gonna reach up and punch
you
yeah i said reach up he's like
you're coming at our role too out here
god damn y'all was cool
what would i be without my baby
i [ __ ] with y'all bro
little my break man we gotta get off we
gotta stop all right guys thank you so
much we're just going into jaw roll this
is a facetime at this point this is a
facetime conversation for me and marty
uh
so what did we learn
marty's a dick with a sound board and i
look like a cop pulling out you look
like a cop
there it is
whoop there it is
uh this was just a sad ass episode and
it started really fun
and i don't remember much and it's very
weird i feel like i just like girls yeah
my brain feels all like i it feels like
i just listen you tune in monday to
watch like everybody else i know i'm
saying like
ugh like usually i can remember what i
was saying what i was looking at when i
said it that's how i remember how to do
like editing but
today was like a blurry day fun day
though
one year one year all right it's been a
year
damn [ __ ] that's crazy so shout
out to john you [ __ ] i had a
segment ready for him for the podcast
too it's gonna be called my dirty uncle
john i was gonna phone him in
and have him talk for a minute and a
half so you guys be exposed to what the
[ __ ] i've been doing
for 20 years what the [ __ ] i've been
exposed to but yo so what did you do
today well you know
and then he just goes crazy
and then shut up mom
i miss it i miss the [ __ ] out of it but
it's all good man
um
maybe we'll get like will sasso to play
him in our movie one day
because he's a will sasso fanatic
his favorite we watched maybe a thousand
times was will sasso's uh segment series
as elvis i can see through metal boys
cutter cutter you guys know what i'm
talking about then yes
maybe will sassa will play his ass one
day and it'll be the tribute to john
because
well sass was a full dude [ __ ] yeah yes
i love him so much he's so funny all
right guys we get out here it's been
three hours and 10 minutes viewer in the
chat shout out to you guys thank you for
everyone in the chat thank you for
everyone rosie thank you for sitting in
the chair and just
being here for the whole time that's
crazy seriously no fan
no fan
hot as [ __ ]
sorry
okay thank you so much for watching
marty thank you for sharing also this
has been
a wild ass episode
did i
eat
food today what i'm thinking
before my hair cut
it's been like 16 hours i just went my
stomach ow
this beer
oh high school not eating just doing
drugs and drinking oh man this is high
school where's johnny
man
for real it's hot
it's hot as [ __ ]
yeah
this is pretty authentic bro i just need
two packs of sinks
and cocoa and some [ __ ] ajax
the ajax oh that was the episode today
that was a long episode man that was
today
yeah
whoa okay thank you guys as joey
lawrence would say
whoa he would not do he would not say
that
yo
what kind of timing was that marty
lawrence would say
train
that was amazing i'm so happy that
happened uh joey lawrence wouldn't say
that we'll get out of here with that
guys thank you for sticking through this
whole [ __ ]
shenanigan
that's all i'm gonna say
shout out to mickey's for making there's
a beer that hurts your stomach a little
i'm just hungry it's just bomb it just
tastes like
minimum wage jobs
that's all i drank when i was drinking
waste
[ __ ] mickey's seoul soul's pretty
good miller high lifes
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] miller highlights
and the podcast all right guys thank you
so much appreciate it shout out to you
if you're uh driving please be [ __ ]
careful uh sorry for marty scaring you
six times in a row with the sound guys
thank you so much for watching uh this
has been
talking about
people that are not here
what do you say all right we'll run with
that well
we should do that as a title talking
about and then just put hell of spaces
people that are not here that would be
[ __ ] stupid
but hilarious to me
do it so much that you can't read on the
first line of youtube titles
people that are
stupid [ __ ]
that's not good
i thought it popped open i hit my mic
sorry i was waiting for my teeth to get
smacked you guys genuinely saw i thought
my teeth were gonna go
that was genuine fear all right guys
you're about to take a sip out of the
mic and [ __ ] no i [ __ ] clicked but i
thought this i thought my [ __ ] was
popping from the forest but it's open
it's your friend that's your homie all
right guys
thank you so much for watching we're
getting out of here we appreciate you
please be safe if you're with your
homies
thank you for watching if you sat
through this whole thing thank you so
much for watching until next time guys
i'm dope yola have a best day
are we still recording right because the
blue it went to blue
marty [ __ ] jumping gangs out here
[Music]
perfect
[Music]